entre eux
salut tout le monde les amis on continue
les prêts doivent donc que doivent faire
les équipes situées dans le top 10 top
14 allée de la loterie de la prochaine
draft prochaine draft le 23 juin
on parle des kings le peut-être la clé
peut-être la clé de cette draft
dans cette émission parle des kings et
comme d'habitude dans les pré draft talk
on a un indiqué médias on a un invité
fans et on a un
un connaisseur un expert je te présente
comme ça un gars qui a regardé beaucoup
de matches cette année en tout cas ça va
lutter en forme
mois 37 ans il travaille chez le trac
quand on vote soit
du côté des fans olive qui représente le
compte twitter king france qui est
habitué depuis très longtemps à
consulter les pages d'envergure il me
semble olive c'est nul c'est tout à fait
exact salut à tous merci pour
l'invitation plaisir d'être là pour
discuter de tout ça mais effectivement
on ont raflé les les prospects
d'envergure et vos articles depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant
malheureusement malheureusement
généralement les n'est pas content de
nous voir on n'est pas content d'elle
fait du bon travail mais si on pouvait
se passer de pouvoir tous des fois
c'est ça et côté est côté médias nous
avons simon ça va sinon
ça va ça va être bah oui c'est un média
côté côté des fans quand même en beauté
chan aussi mais je sais pas comment des
présentes et tu vois tu as toutes les
casquettes là ce soir
c'est vrai que je suis juge et partie on
va dire mr se marie aussi quoi robert se
marie aussi c'est ça c'est possible
parce que les le panel des scénarios qui
se dessine pour ce pic 4 et quand même
hyper hyper hyper grands alors comme
d'habitude on a fonctionné en quand même
en plusieurs parties on va essayer de
structurer notre notre pensée pour aller
tout doucement vers que doit faire
l'équipe ski drafté ou qui ne pas drafté
vous quitterez idée on verra ça plus
tard mais d'abord on va faire un bilan
sinon je commence par toi
2022 ça veut dire quoi l'identité kings
quel est le projet
ben elle à elle à rebondir l'été
remodelé autour du train dès l'arrivée
de sabonis
puisque c'est vraiment quand même l'idée
d'associer cette faire sa valise fox
tout le jeu avait l'air de 20 ils ont
joué un échantillon de match avant que
la saison soit un peu c'est pas vraiment
du temps de 18 ans qui il ya la fin mais
sans n'était pas vraiment pas non plus
j'avais cette espèce de sa durée jusqu'à
un dernier match mais avant ta ta un
échantillon de sa peau ni stock sous le
ddea vert quand même de deux places et à
parts égales on va dire les deux en tant
que moteur du jeu est quasiment
d'impliquer personne d'autre que pendant
tout le jeu c'est à eux deux
autour de cette paire avec mon général
fox d'araignée trois points sabonis au
postaux c'est vraiment le point de
départ les autres en position fixe tu
vas avoir à ce moment là plutôt l'idée
d'un spécifique avec ce qui avait le
bric à brac
tu tentes et vincenzo il y avait même
langue et où c'était ça l'idée quoi
voilà alors que avant il y avait plus
une identité de jeu avec deux porteurs
de balle halliburton et fox
sur les lignes arrières ou en tout cas à
l'extérieur et un jeu sont de plus
rapide qui coache moins de 15 en 2001
dur parce que tu avais vraiment
quasiment rien à l'intérieur
voilà pour résumer je passe j'ai eu
l'idée
la jupe est quelque chose de les gérer
même si m ouais j'y ai même encore plus
loin que simon disons que quand même
tout le jeu en fait passe par ça passe
par sabonis en fait on même si on a
comme tu le dis un axe fox sabonis
aujourd'hui autour duquel le jeu est
centré en fait on voit que sabonis en
fait est vraiment le point de fixation
en attaque c'est souvent lui des fois
qu'ils montent même la balle sans
transition ou même surface de surface de
jeu posé sa passe évidemment par lui
posté au poste bas etc
faire des passes de faire du hand of en
postaux etc donc j'ai l'impression
vraiment que il ya eu il ya eu c'est
vrai cette volonté de l'intégrer
vraiment directement dans le jeu
profiter de ses qualités
comme a dit simon s'était dit vraiment
des temps king est vraiment du wind
cette fin de saison c'était un peu
bizarre
c'était plus d'une espèce de version
bêta test pour voir si fox sabonis ça
fonctionne et ça fonctionne mais voilà
il va falloir ensuite bien l'entourer
doc et quelles sont les ambitions
assumer pour la saison à venir est ce
qu'il y en a déjà qui sont sortis et par
voie de presse ou bruit par rumeurs
c'est toujours un petit peu les mêmes
après on aura toujours droit à quoi la
langue de bois chaque conférence de
presse de début de saison qui sera
évidemment l'objectif c'est toujours les
playoffs
d'autant plus maintenant qu'on a pété le
record le timer ndzié donc là voilà j'ai
l'impression qu'il est vraiment une
volonté de la franchise d'arrêter de les
utiliser
d'aller de l'avant de construire quelque
chose de solide et de gagner donc ouais
bah évidemment le projet c'est minimum
minimum pline j'ai envie de te dire voir
playoffs parce que si tu arrives à
construire quelque chose de correct
autour de foxy sabonis tu peux quand
même sans prétendre tout de suite à de
très hautes trait aux résultats tu peux
prétendre être quand même une équipe
compétitive à l'ouest
salut à tous le monde dans le chatt
envoyer vos questions
si vous en avez j'essaie de les retenir
un petit peu on les prendra un petit peu
au fil au fil de l'eau au cours d'eau
cours de ce live simon tu voulais
ajouter quelque chose
non c'est l'objectif c'est le plaisir
effectivement et j'ajouterais c'est
aussi d'avoir une structure des équipes
qui on va dire même si elle rate de peu
le pays nous voilà à qui tu as envie de
donner une deuxième chance une trois
cycles on va dire quelque chose sur
lequel tu peux dire pendant deux trois
ans on a un noyau qui normalement
devrait atteindre les playoffs tu serais
je pense que tout accord avec le plugin
l'an prochain et être blé aux fab 2 3
ans et ça on va le voir ça va ça va
quand même déjà fortement influencé ce
qu'ils vont faire la draft
parce que c'est pas du long terme tu
peut paraître un peu à du moyen terme tu
dois être pas tu dois faire le plein à
court terme mais tu dois te renforcer
aussi vraiment surtout à moyen terme
pour que pendant des deux trois quatre
prochaines années on parle des kings
comme une équipe qui normalement bon et
et dans le bade et en playoffs et dans
le pays une playoffs mais de manière
assez sûre et régulière sur un site de 3
ans je pense que c'est pas uniquement
faire un coup et attraper une fois le
président pour mac nerfs en tout cas
c'est vraiment monter aussi une équipe
qui est capable de le faire plus d'une
fois quoi il a la pression avec nerfs
sur cette draft
sur cette grave sur l'indiquent ment pas
forcément parce qu'il a déjà prouvé
quand même qu'ils draft est bien qu'il a
peut-être un joker soit grave par contre
sur l'été et sur l'équipe qui doit se
pointer à la rentrée là il a la pression
je pense mais je pense que c'est pas
uniquement sur la draft
ouais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
avec simon je pense qu'il ya quand même
même si c'est un petit peu caché même si
ce n'est pas vraiment explicite je pense
qu'il ya quand même une pression sur les
épaules de mac nerfs
et son contrat son premier contrat tant
que james se termine cet été et on avait
entendu de source sûre proche de
sacramento que les discussions sur sa
prolongation n'était même pas encore en
cours voilà c'est quand même assez
inquiétant quand on souhaite mettre un
projet en place mais ça en dit long sur
le fait que bon il a quand même
quand même un espèce d'enjeux sur la
saison qui arrive peut-être qu'on est
inutilement paranoïaque qui va être
prolongé cet été on ne sait pas mais
voilà il ya quand même il ya quand même
ce petit indice qui nous dit que ben il
n'est pas complètement s'il n'est pas en
danger mais il n'est pas complètement
sec non plus quoi il va falloir montrer
des choses c'est de saison s'il veut pas
commencer à avoir peur pour sa place
quoi
c'est ça alors la première question que
je vais vous poser y compris à hull qui
va peut-être répondra le deuxième partie
de la question est ce qu'il faut le
draft et est ce qu'on va drafté speak 4
ou pas alors il ya deux il ya deux
questions est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
le faire ça c'est un peu du madame irma
un peu flou on peut pas savoir et
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils devraient
le faire voilà est-ce qui est ce qui
vaudra tout explique 4 simon
ben on va dire est-ce qu'ils vont sans
doute essayer d'avoir de voir ce qu'ils
peuvent avoir en échange je pense que ça
par contre c'est assez établi on a même
c'est le boulot je pense en plus d'un
bon deuxième d'aller voir un peu ce que
tu peux avoir comme et on connaît le
schéma ce serait un vétéran et de
descendre de 2,3 peut-être quatre ans
pas beaucoup plus à la draft
apparemment ce serait ça l'idée où
effectivement prendre en quatre après
est-ce que après c'est là où tout de
suite je vais un peu décortiquer le truc
mais tu peux tout aussi bien prendre
quatre un des deux meilleurs joueurs etc
qui à la fois va à peu près à ce que tu
fais mais a aussi une très bonne valeur
marchande parce que quand tant que tu
n'avais pas drafté tu n'as pas eu
d'offre qui t'a fait appuyer sur le
bouton et qui t'a fait accepté neuf si
on te propose un exemple et indiana te
dis malcom braff donne epixis contre
l'alpi de 4 tu peux dire non drafté
quelqu'un ou quatre et plus tard leur
maître lui sur la table pour un échange
en cours de saison
donc je l'impression qu'en en ayant fait
cet âge où je t'ai voile un peu déjà ma
stratégie ou ce que je pense qu'ils
devraient être la stratégie un peu du
juste milieu et de de ce qu'il faut
faire avec avec ce pic parce que je vais
finir là-dessus mais tu as quand même la
chance d'être monté à la loterie tu as
quand même la chance de draft et plus
haut prévu et dans une rafle où on le
voit quand même il ya normalement pitt
cate ya pas de de tingry avant et tout a
quand même l'assurance d'avoir du talent
quoi
oui mais même s'il ya des degrés avant
il ya encore plus l'assurance de mes
collègues et moi j'aime bien mal comme
brockton mais je préfère le talentueux
le mouël et annonçant un accord si non
mais jamais ce joueur là même si je me
démerde après
cela aussi de dons donc toi le graphe
voilà toi tu vois ce qu'on peut avoir en
échange mais faudrait pour toi il
faudrait beaucoup pour te faire renoncer
à un potentiel jackpot du coup si c'est
ça disons que je vois ce qui va faire en
échange ouais c'est ça c'est même encore
plus simple je vois ce que j'ai en
échange mais je garde en tête que je
peux tout à fait faire un échange avec
eux que j'ai gratté plus tard en le
mettant dans des super coqs pour bonnes
conditions pour qu'il brille parce que
je sais que c'est un talent et je les
change ou je fais un autre échange alors
dans mon effectif
aux livres objets drafté de le soir de
la draft
ouais je pense je pense que
comme toute équipe du top un peu on fait
un peu monter les en fait un peu monter
les enchères deux ans avant la drave et
je trouve ça plutôt normal plutôt sain
en fait ça me surprend pas dans la
mesure en fait on a hérité d'un pic qui
même s'il est bien plus haut que ce
qu'on a imaginé quand même un petit peu
comment dire un petit peu bâtard dans le
sens où on a un vrai top 3 qui se dégage
est le quatrième tu peux te permettre
d'aborder tout autant dans le top 3 tu
prends n'importe lequel d'orly grain
banque héros ou smith qui reste autant
en sortant du cadre tu peux commencer à
se poser des questions c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il ya que ya ces discussions
autour autour du pic 4 qu' il ya des
rumeurs vrai ou pas qui disent que on
est en train de chercher un mec nba
ready pour l'associer aux pour monter un
trade avec ce pic
j'y crois j'y crois sans y croit parce
que je pense que mac n'est rackham assez
intelligents pour se dire qu'un 4 ça
arrive pas tous les quatre matins
surtout dans une cuve et où il ya quand
même pour relativement pas mal de talent
il ya des choses à faire
donc je trouve que je trouve les rumeurs
autour du pic normal mais je pense que
je pense qu'on va drafté en 4 je reste
certain qu'on reste à des coupes des
offres c'est normal ça moi j'ai pas de
souci avec ça mais je pense qu'on va
leur alter encadré nous trouver
l'opportunité de se renforcer par une
gomme en toiture relativise le
le talent potentiellement disponible en
4 par rapport à d'autres cuvée alors
plus passée que future puisque futur on
connaît un peu mais encore pas très très
bien
on va pas trop se projeter à la déjà
vous dire à quoi les bonnes et n'hésite
pas à me couper un bras message si
jamais cela se trompent pas parce que ce
soir on est loin de la compagnie pour
seniors
on est bien mieux je suis pédaler ma
femme derrière pour avoir de
l'électricité et apparat légal donc
voilà faut pas hésiter
effectivement en terme de deux talents
on est sur une cuve et peut-être où il
ya moins de créateurs ballom hamon admet
qu'ils peuvent arriver et être le visage
franchise au bout de trois quatre ans et
a mené une attaque à voir du scoring
drame aux années précédentes où on avait
plus de choses comme ça on a moins de ce
qu'on appelle deux jours générationnel
ou de franchise player comme on aime
bien mettre le site en épluchant une
cuvée avec des peut-être des pelotes
deuxième option voire troisième au sein
d'une équipe
et ça les kings ils sont dans une
situation un peu particulière comme vous
l'avait bien dit pas ce qu'on comprend
c'est que la semaine et le deuxième à ce
qu'on voit dans les workouts où il va il
a déjà vu plus d'une trentaine
quarantaine de joueurs et il les voit
tous les niveaux il y regarde des
joueurs qui seraient disponibles top 4
mais des jours un peu plus bas des
joueurs vraiment du top 3 parce que
disait sedrata trois joueurs moi je suis
pas particulièrement d'accord là dessus
on est plus sur cinq six joueurs dans
cette draft en rajoutant aux notre ami
sharp travail vyntra milles et jean guy
finn si certains veulent proposer jean
guy finn et
hans à lui se laisse toutes les options
moi je serais pas surpris
personnellement on recule un tout petit
peu en fonction de la cote d'un mec
comme magic wheel clean justement et
qu'on aille voir où est ce qu'on peut
aller le chopper et c'est de savoir ce
que les autres et qui peuvent faire à ce
niveau là pour moi ils vont charger la
meca seridi les kings tout en niant tout
en gardant delà du talent la
potentialité mais ils seront ils savent
qu'ils n'auront pas un énorme créature
balle en main donc de là ils vont
peut-être à chercher le meilleur
complément possible à leur père qu'ils
ont déjà installé c'est intéressant
parce que ces bases ne sais pas du tout
ce qu'on dit
simon et olive parce que dans en
filigrane dans ce qui transparaissait
c'était plus si on peut avoir zhai de na
vi ou shannon sharpe c'est à dire
potentiellement des joueurs qui vont
quand même porté le ballon qui vont
avoir besoin du ballon pour briller
on va les prendre simon c'est est-ce que
c'était un petit peu ce que tu pensais
quand tu parlais de potentiel djagassa
ça ouais le point d'inflexion en fait
j'étais sûr en gros tu ne sois tu doives
pas donc dans la stratégie de lutte tu
ne vas pas en 4 tu choisis tout de suite
d'aller chercher j'imagine ont si
souvent c'est un truc comme ça griffin
et tu grattes un joueur donc soit de
sindian à portland il y en a aux
portland est-ce qu'en 5 bon voila tu
grattes ça et je comprends et c'est tout
à fait logique parce que d'un point de
vu comment c'est même le plus
intelligent parce que effectivement le
but c'est de se renforcer à court terme
est de prendre un joueur performant très
rapidement mais moi je trouve qu assez
vite peut-être que je me trompe pas mais
parce que je suis pas assez convaincu
par griffin par exemple ou par les
rafales c'est des bons joueurs qui vont
être parfois on dit mais je me dis que
drafté par exemple sharp où elle vit le
faire briller
tout temps normalement gagnant quelques
matchs quand même il va c'est pas c'est
pas griffe hidoussa je pense que tu sois
d'accord aulas ne s'est pas la
différence entre griffin écharpe tout de
suite en nba où il vit qui va influencer
sur 15 victoires sur
je pense pas et tu peux comme ça assez
vite monter un trait d'ici février ou
peut-être tu peux avoir un meilleur
joueur quelques fines ou que le vétéran
que tu allais gratianne à portland grâce
au talent de sharp où elle vit j'ai
l'impression que c'est possible
voilà moi j'ai l'impression quand même
qualifié charges sont des griffin ça va
être c'est pas que ça un rôle player non
plus hein pas du tout mais il n'a pas ce
truc électrisant il n'a pas ce truc qui
fait un peu vendre aussi qui des
highlights etc j'ai l'impression quand
même qualifiés ou chats sont des joueurs
plus sexy en fait fondamentalement et
pour on peut permettre rapidement de
monter un trade où tu auras ce 3 4
meilleurs et performant en cours de
saison que jean guy finn que keegan
murray que voilà que c'est profil
d'ailier qui sont les plus hauts dans
les bords de tout le monde
unis lesquels parmi tous ceux qu'on a
cité avant qu'on commence un petit peu à
rentrer dans les noms lesquels on work
out pas dit
que tadic avait étudié les work out des
kings parmi les autres tableaux je te
demande pas
si gabriel et procida
alors là j'ai pas mal 2,2 soit encore
une fois je suis désolé halak océan ce
soir
le premier qui est sorti cette jeune
fille le premier sens pour ça que j'en
ai parlé là c'est que c'est le premier
cas est interviewé en même temps que
charte ils ont évolué
17.10 vie j'ai encore une fois on sait
que mcnair il aime bien les sentais
bien je te coupe mon ego aussi que je te
coupe le sifflet en tant qu on pense la
nana resort il aurait pris avec plus
connus
ouais vas-y sa coupe ce que je te coupe
je te coupe ouais je te coupe on n'a pas
compris tout à fait ce que tu avais dit
essaye de essaye d'appeler tu vois le
réseau tu appelles free tu dis voilà
valence j'ai un podcast c'est important
olive toit par les prospects
voix parmi les bruits qui ressortent de
sacramento les work out qui ont été
faits les interviews etc quel est le
prospect a le plus de buzz en mode les
kings aime bien
alors je vais dire malheureusement mais
c'est pas exactement le sens de mon
propos
c'est qu'ils gagneraient en fait dès le
dlan oms du pic 4 partout sur le king
twitter tu entendais des bienvenue qui
calmerait machin donc voilà j'avais
l'impression que les américains sont
vraiment très à fond sur sur ce joueur
ce que je peux comprendre dans un sens
puisque c'est quand même un très bon
joueur qui a notamment porté son équipe
cette année mais mais voilà j'ai
l'impression que lui c'est un joueur qui
a la cote ensuite en y réfléchissant un
peu j'ai l'impression que ça mentionné
du shard du ivy mais c'est pas aller
beaucoup plus loin j'ai l'impression que
les gens se projette plus sûr on va
draft est encadrée on regarde quel est
le meilleur talent a été le meilleur
talent disponibles
ce qui ressort des workouts et qu'on a
interviewé tous ces mecs là en fait pour
compléter ce que disait parce que je
sais pas si tout le monde a bien entendu
du coup de tête on a évidemment vu ou
aigris fils on a vu meurent et on a vu
sharp on a vu à vie
parmi les parmi les têtes d'affiché donc
voilà ça aussi ça morde qu'on se laisse
un peu tout les toutes les portes
ouvertes et et aucun du voile a été
baptisé en top 3 des
balances misano
j'ai pas j'ai pas vu passer la news ou
alors peut-être qu'ils ont refusé les
work out
mais je sens
jarjat j'ai un vague doute n'y a pas eu
mathurin j'ai un doute mais non c'est
beau c'est possible moi je les donne
strange là mais c'est être un peu au
fond mais j'ai déjà un vague doute mais
je
sais que c'est possible on a vu beaucoup
de monde dans le règne aussi de re la
dre loterie après voilà je sens les noms
qui me venaient de l eau le top 5 la
voilà c'est un peu un peu tout ce qui a
été vu
alors hughes est de retour normalement
avec une bonne connexion alors j'espère
j'espère j'ai donné des coups de feu
puis droite après je fais de mon mieux
on parle
alors olive nous disait bas qui gagnent
murray c'était le premier nom qui était
ressorti non mais attends arrête de
faire un nom comme ça je te demande déjà
de me présenter le joueur pour les
personnes qui ne le connaissent pas ou
qui n'ont vu que des caricatures en peu
de caractère sur twitter
et qui gagnent le voit c'est un ailier
qui a joué iowa dans la big ten qui est
une des plus grosses conférences il ya
michigan qui casse tête aux
grosses fac sans sophomore donc un
deuxième année il est arrivé avec son
frère jumeau à la crise murray dans une
équipe qui l'an dernier avait le joueur
qui a été élu joueur de l'année avec lui
karzaï pivot peut-être un peu connue
maintenant sept ans carette s'adapter
et il prend les mains de l'équipe de
saint hélier qui a montré qu'il pouvait
et shooter de partout qui a montré au
niveau et si je précise au niveau initié
des caps se crée son propre tir du la
qualité pour aller au finir au panier où
il a très très bien terminée malgré un
manque de qualités athlétiques sur le
premier
dans la partie qualité dans la puissance
son côté du terrain c'est un joueur
défensivement qui défendent très bien
les ailiers qui montre beaucoup de qi
basket toujours très très bien passé
toujours dans les bonnes rotations qui
voit là peut tenir plusieurs profils
aura pas la cas pas se défendre des
arrières nba et huawei ce qu'on n'en
parle pas forcément aussi bien que les
américains parce qu'on croit pas ici à
la cité du jour est créé son propre tir
à la capacité du joueur à exister comme
il existait en termes de table de haut
niveau une ciel qu on le projette plus
sur un joueur qui va voir un seul
roulement poser des écrans épopée à
trois points et ce à une valeur ce à un
coût d'avis bertone si je t'ai s'agit là
dessus et le personnage et s'est dit là
dessus mais c'est pas un quatrième jeune
grâce voilà tout simplement
ils vont pas être d'accord si tu dis ce
que tu as et reese halliburton est pas
un quatrième choix ce
que je veux dire
ian murray c'est un joueur qui shoote
bien qui est capable de jouer sans
ballon qui capable de punir des switchs
tout à l'heure si mon tu parles est un
petit peu et olive aussi de 7,7 cette
centralisation autour de sabonis postaux
en tout cas au début des systèmes et
aussi des pick and roll pour fox est ce
qu'un joueur comme ça peut profiter
du fait que sabonis bah voilà face à
face ressortir plutôt le joueur qui va
défendre sur les gros en face et
profiter du match up profiter des
espaces pour ses tirs qu'est ce que vous
pensez encore que il ya d'écrit du fitr
potentiel non m'a quand même au niveau
du feed qui vient de muret c'est pas
point que son nom sans re premier a
priori le plus gros manques dans
l'effectif des kings c'est sur les ailes
post 3 ou 4 en gros le seul joueur le
seul le titulaire nba la danse harrison
barnes et il a quand même somme on est
toujours associé trade et c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait arriver encore de son
explorer tout et après c'est hier sur
les anneaux kings tas mais tous qui
permet malgré tout très live qui cache
des postes 4 et je pense que poste 3
c'était selon les sacs commence était
composée c'était soit jérémy lampe soit
divine zoo qui boucher les trous passe
de trois
je portais me l'acheter 1000e l'effectif
ans dans l'année prochaine c'est avec le
service alors que à l'arrière tu as fuck
je retrouve vincenzo tu avais justin
alizés qui jouait aussi parfois ça
s'était dit fin de saison est jim lee
des avoirs qui jouent et 3 quoi là
dedans mais les ailes sont plus des
peuples et que les arrières où tu as
quand même un bon meneur fox etc touton
qui gagnent murray pour revenir à lui
si on parle de fitte
c'est peut-être le joueur qu'il faut
prendre en tout cas c'est un des tout
premiers n'ont plus qu'un c'est évident
maintenant il ya cet adage déjà que
dante quand tu piques très haut tu fais
pas au feat mais surtout si c'est pour
draft est une version améliorée et plus
jeunes d'entre elles hines c'est pas la
peine ou d'un joueur ou d'un ménage
exane entre l as pas au niveau talent
était à cannes du film machete mais je
parle de l'utilisation qu'on dans le jeu
des kings parce que c'est pas un joueur
qui va déborder en dribble c'est pas un
joueur qui va se créer son shoot et nous
vu ce qu'on propose cette fois aussi par
qui on est les kings on va on va lui
proposer de faire quoi bah en fait de
faire ce que fait très la kz2 de prendre
le temps de jeu très lines en poste 4
oui va le faire mieux parce qu'il est
plus jeune notamment parce que je suis
même pas sûr qu'il a meilleur shoot à
trois points très live mais en tout cas
il a un côté un peu plus scoreur naturel
plus talentueux notamment près du cercle
et où je trouve dans ses mouvements mais
il sait pas si plat fin c'est pas et
vous voyez ce que je veux dire et on a
déjà quelqu'un qui fait 70 % qui gagnent
murray s'est pas insultant de dire que
très light l'an prochain pourra faire ça
et pour cadre un million la saison 3 est
peut-être un complément le sud rate ça
c'est jusque dans semaine dans cette
draft l'achipel draft énorme en terme de
talent il ya des mecs sur le post qui
gagnerait qui feront peut-être mieux
d'ici deux trois ans que keegan le
vannes oc même sur la draft en elle même
tu as tu d'autres joueurs avec de la
potentialité chaud même profil qu'ils
feront mieux peut-être et qui
apporteront plus atone et qui les deux
côtés du terrain
tout à fait il a déjà 22 ans
va les avoir très bientôt il va les
avoir très bientôt donc son son ca
marche de développement et plus fluide
il ya mois de développement dans se voit
normalement que par exemple j'ai
l'impression que tu pensais à lui mais
quelqu'un comme griffin par exemple
alors pour moi c'est pas le même poste
mais pour moi c'est janet robinson
ouais alors à part contrite style
justice adam 4 c
ça me paraît compliqué contre les kings
parce que pour moi c'est
celle là c'est la même comparaison pour
moi ils sont dans le même peu présentes
car j'ai même l'islam plus haut mais
il sonne soran randall ball on est sur
des profils un peu similaire est
quasiment
devant qui gagnent le rythme est clos
tu as quand même
après avoir dit
non mais c'est vrai si on regarde le big
board envergure hughes est quand même un
des plus pessimistes sur la botte de
keegan murray quand même bien devant
manny qui las d'attendre 7e mais voilà
nous on l'a tous entre eux disent aidant
les personnes là dans le top10 quoi bein
non mais voilà donc moi je m'entraîne
encore que c'est un joueur efficace
et qui va qui va apporter de suite moi
ce qui me gêne juste avec le fait que le
nom de keegan murray ressort tout de
suite en cas c'est qu'on donne
l'impression qu'on est une équipe qui a
pas d'ambition quoi un excellent ces
cinq ans comme on l'a dit comme l'a dit
c'est un bon joueur et il n'y a pas de
problème orphée probablement dans une
équipe il va faire son il doit faire son
taf mais c'est juste d'aller chercher
des joueurs avec dd au plancher et
débats plafond à 60 ans 4 1 mais cap
presque 22 ans voilà qui dont le
développement sera probablement rue
devrait probablement atteindre 10 dans
ses premières années voilà c'est juste
moi juste que je reproche à la franchise
des eaux liée aux fans de manière plus
générale aussi c'est de ne pas vous
pensez un peu plus peut penser de ne pas
avoir un peu la big picture et de se
dire voilà on essaie de de prendre un
mec on est encore patient est ce qu on a
attendu 16 ans est ce qu'on peut
attendre les deux ans plus que
développer un mec qui aura trois fois
plus de talent que keegan murray dans
deux ans voilà je sais juste être cette
façon de penser qui à chaque draft et ça
en fait un shack draft c'est le même le
profil de joueurs qui sortent et des
joueurs très assez vieux des rookie
développer tout niké l'année dernière ma
vision voilà par exemple qu'ils savaient
restreint de façon des kicks mai mais
voilà pardon pardon si mon jeu mais
voilà c'est un john mitchell qui s'avère
être un bon pique qui gagnent murray qui
serait également un bon pique si on me
prenait c'est juste que je trouve ça pas
très ambitieux tu contente de la zone de
confort tu dis ok le joueur essaye je
sais qu'il va m'apporter ça mais tu veux
tu vois pas plus loin mais simon dans ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure sur voilà
est-ce qu'on va pas prendre un mec qui
va avoir de la valeur rapidement pour
pouvoir en tirer quelque chose qui
gagnerait il peut rentrer quand même
pour moi qui gagnerait s'il est si les
drafté dans une équipe où il a un vrai
rôle c'est un vrai favori rookie of the
year
côté production c'est un late bloomer il
va encore progresser il a progressé
encore quand la saison même s'il a déjà
22 ans
mais je pense qu aux kings il sera trop
limité dans son utilisation quoi ouais
avec cette domination de sabonis qui a
déjà besoin de la balle plus de fox qui
va tourner autour plus quand même un
tout petit peu on va voir si jen va être
signée tout mais il ya des joueurs il ya
des joueurs qui vont aussi il va être là
dedans il va être vraiment dans les
dents les joueurs autour de fox et
sabonis et je suis pas sûr que ce soit
un environnement pour le faire briller
pour en faire un candidat rookie tanner
et
et avoir de là quelque chose de très
conséquents en échange par contre qu'ils
gagnent murray si les kings ne veulent
vraiment
pourquoi pas aller très tarn pour lui tu
vas aller discuter avec indiana et parce
que je pense qu'on 6 tu l'as toujours
oui en tout cas il a pas eu de buzz à
des trois noms mais après ça surtout la
plus si tu l'as plus tu as quand même
gratter un vétéran quelque chose est à
toujours du coup bas griffin ou et ses
attaquants même toujours un ailier qui
fit et la personne viendra dire enfin
des produits talons et tout parce que
tuft a sécurisé sa est ce que bon bah
avec jeux par mois déjà la migrante si
c'est étroit avec michael bolton ça on a
passé six et diana je sais plus qui
s'était pour portland qui était dans les
trucs pour séchage de la charte non un
truc comme ça josh arieh ils vont
peut-être signés zhang jing laisse aussi
bon bah ça veut dire si on concrétise
tout ça ça veut dire que les kings
traders draft griffin ou qu'ils gagnent
leurs haies en 7 et ramasse charte bah
franchement je préfère prendre
me dis que si c'est pour faire ça je
garde mon pic catch penchard pour avis
je joue
le deuxième cinq c'est tous les ballons
rookie avec en gros davienne mutuel en
développement je m'en fous c'est mon
deuxième sac je peux film mon truc je
vais chercher un ailier ça on verra plus
tard éventuellement à la free agency de
toute façon mon eau qui va pas m'aider
autour de la coque sabonis etc par
contre le deuxième sac c'est pour lui
quoi il briller tout est soit je me
rends compte que bah en fait c'est
incroyable et je revois mes plans parce
que sharp où elle vit à terme prouve
qu'ils sont qui peuvent être vite
meilleur que fox
soit en fait ils prouvent et ça c'est le
jackpot qui sont complémentaires de fox
et le sabonis et que je peux les
intégrer dans le cinq parce que la nba
est très moderne et qu'en fait un avis
poste 2 bat ça passe sharp con ça passe
post 2 voir post 3 la séméga jackpot et
tout ça en fait je n'ai pas moi j'ai pas
cette espèce de truc où je sens un
jackpot voyez ce que je veux dire avec
ivy ça marche ça devient un titulaire
post 2 avec sharp ça marche ça devient
le tuteur passe de trois je n'ai pas
dans mon dans mon alliage chart qui
gagnent murray ou zhou djarrah migrantes
et jean guy finn par exemple je ne sais
pas
leur unique avant de te filer le mic sur
sûr qu'ils gagnent juste moi ce qui me
fait douter personnellement et quand
même que mike schmid cela en 5 dans son
bord à lui personnel mike schmid c'est
quelqu'un qui vient d'être embauché en
tant que assistant gm à portland c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît très bien le
basket qui s'est rarement beaucoup
trompé c'est parfois un peu trompé mais
il s'est rarement beaucoup trompé quand
même sur les évaluations de joueurs je
suis surpris et après il a un bon
argumentaire il dit voilà dans cette
draft ya pas de superstar c'est un gars
qui va avoir une production tout de
suite et qui a aussi un plafond pour
être voilà un joueur complémentaire 1 1
crise middleton du un peu pauvre quoi
mais un plafond quand même assez élevé
avec un gars qui peut créer sur un
dribble qui peut punir les matchs sur un
ou deux dribbles que ce soit au poste
avec puissance et un gars qui shoote
après mouvement parce que c'est ça la
clé du développement de keegan murray à
mon avis si tu joues 406 shoot après
mouvement comme il l'a montré sur
certains matches lui apprendre des
cascades d'écrans où il va prendre des
hand of et c'est là tu peux le faire
jouer avec alex sabonis tu peux le faire
jacques fox peut le faire jouer avec
n'importe qui puisque toute façon il
apporte de l'espace dont on attaque une
vas-y
mais j'allais en plus arriver là dessus
c'est que c'est pas particulièrement les
kings qui l'ont en quatre ces espionnes
qu'il la top 5 est sage une différence
parce qu'on sait pas en fait ce que
l'éthique disons c'est que ces mecs là
ils sont projetés 4,5 comme halliburton
et et cat's paw kouassi et nous n'y
croyais pas partie ferrand mais ils
étaient quatre cinq six espionne ou
obito pinette et 4,5 chine espionne et
finalement il est tombé un peu plus bas
donc maintenant la question c'est de
savoir qui fait ses ses mots clés
espionne pour quelles raisons ils le
font et qu'est ce qu'ils voient pas ce
que
ça secret de polichinelle polichinelle
que max ne citait pas exactement les
mots lui ve il a son propre style à son
propre board et que chi espionne
on vend quand même un produit
oui assez assez conventionnelle les
seniors aux donc voilà c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder
après s'ils gagnent heures pour boucler
sur le joueur oui parce que je peux et a
dit simon sur la complémentarité sur le
jeu of paul ii a été hyper intéressant
et pour moi c'est vrai c'est que toutes
les cases de ce que le dixième attendre
et c'est un joueur qui va être efficace
dans les avancées cette avancée qui peut
être productif tout de suite qui peut
très bien s'intégrer sans demander le
ballon qui peut faire peut-être le sale
travail défensif que sabonis où harrison
bras ne peuvent pas trop faire en tout
cas elle le projet est là dessus et qui
peut très rapidement jouer dans une
équipe qui se veut compétitive donc là
dessus et coach des cases maintenant je
suis plus en tant que membre envergure
logique de on prend à hillion prochain
où un joueur avec un peu plus de
potentiel comme je le dis parce que je
n'ai pas de vent qui gagnerait mais
c'est ce qu'ils font qu' on peut le
projeter peut-être top 5 chez ea
espionne ou d'autres grosses boucles par
rapport à la tendance américaine
olive qui tu préfères toi mais juste
vas-y vas-y fini tituba vas-y non mais
je voulais rajouter dans une petite
question pour terminer ouais pour
terminer sur qui gagnent murray parce
que j'entends lui que parler du coût de
sa défense est une question sur
qu'est-ce que ce qu'on pense de ce que
vous pensez en fait de la défense de
keegan murray parce que j'ai lu il s'en
est train sans avoir vraiment très
approfondie c'est qu'ils manquaient de
mobilité latéral et que sur les
séquences défensives défendre sur des
ailiers ça pouvait lui poser problème
qu'il était un bon défenseur en second
rideau notamment un plutôt bon contreur
mais que voilà sur sa mobilité ce n'est
pas encore ça ce que vous confirmez
ses analyses
avec sont plus chocs mondiaux 6 pilotes
moi je trouve discipline et je trouve
intelligent sur ses placements
je trouve qu'il a une vraie lecture loin
du ballon d'ailleurs il et c'est pour ça
qu'il est bon dans les stades avancés
c'est parce qu'il a des que ce soit au
niveau des styles ce que ce au niveau
des blocks iil il crée des événements
défensif au sein d'une défense ce qui
est on peut quand même le souligner est
très rare pour un joueur qui avait sa
charge offensive
en haut niveau un ciel généralement ils
ont un peu tendance à se reposer en
défense ils étaient vraiment présent
défense était capable de prendre le
meilleur scoreur intérieurs adverses en
3 4 5
évidemment il défend pas sur des sur des
petits évident à kiki qui défend enfin
en poste 4 de cette grave peut-être
harrison défenseur des petits mais sinon
sinon il ya personne
faut être réaliste légumes sont là on
est en train de regarder les playoffs
évidemment c'est le haut du panier mais
mais à voir la latéralité pour tenir en
un contre un un gars comme comme stephen
curry sens comme le la crème de la scène
là
bas ça n'existe pas à la draft et c'est
normal et c'est pour ça que moi je
préfère un joueur intelligent et qu'il
va je suis assez sûr que j'achète sa
défense collective et la manière dont
ils s'intègrent dans un effectif et un
système défensif plus ou moins complexes
on n'a pas parlé de la défense commence
à fonctionner des kings mais tu pourras
m'ont parlé oliva ça fonctionne pas
ça fonctionne pas c'est pour ça que
c'est français
qu'est ce qui manque qu'est ce qui
manque à cette réponse alors pour toi il
y manque lui manque des mecs qui ont
envie de défendre en fait tout
simplement on l'a vu un petit peu on a
vu on allait se vend très cher avec des
vieux ni ciel cette année qui vraiment
un cdd d'un gris en défense a prouvé
qu'il était arrêtez moi si jean énormité
mais déjà parmi les meilleurs gordes
défenseur de n'diaye tout simplement en
fait
et
il fait de belles oreilles c'est le
fonds seront pas d'accord
et ouais du coup voilà c'est le problème
qu'à ce que fox il porte déjà beaucoup
en attaque du coup la défense ça passe
ça passe au second plan sabonis il était
un peu les efforts mais bon on voit qui
est vraiment il manque un peu comme son
père il manque un peu de la mobilité
qu'il faut pour les défendre
correctement et tout voilà même si une
envie de défendre il faut arriver à
instaurer une défense collective avec
des mecs qui ont envie de qui ont envie
de défendre en fait des gars qui sont
capables de s'intégrer dans une dans une
défense collective c'est un peu aussi on
a un indice avec l'arrivée de mike brown
a reconnu comme un spécialiste défensif
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya quand même
cette volonté de monter mcn r2 voilà
maintenant j'ai l'impression qu'il en a
assez vu quitter bon voilà c'est bon ça
suffit qu'on fout de la gueule des kings
parce qu'on défend pas maintenant on va
essayer de faire quelque chose on pourra
lui reprocher que ça n'avait pas marché
on pourra pas lui reprocher de pas avoir
essayé en tout cas voilà il faut souffle
il faut un joueur en tout cas qui qui
arrive un minimum
à produire en défense quoi
oliver gedo nagui ou shannon sharpe
oh là là c'est pas facile parce comme
jeudi soir quand il fait le programme
j'étais chez toi ici les programmes on
parle de qui tu veux
je au début dès que des comme avec peter
qui est sorti j'étais beaucoup plus sur
celle de sharp aujourd'hui je m'oriente
un peu sur john hayes vie je sais pas
j'ai une petite ipod sud en asie en ce
moment voilà j'échange avec pas mal de
monde sur twitter qui est beaucoup plus
experts que moi au maintien de draft moi
je suis un expert draft minutes
highlights youtube donc
je est également en lisant quelques
articles par ci par là mais j'ai quand
même l'impression que
tu peux en prenant jedi vie faire
quelque chose le nom en mettant à côté
de fox faire un parcours vraiment super
sonic un truc sympa après mon ma seule
question c'est
dans cette attaque on a on va besoin
désespérément de shooter pour étirer le
jeu parce que tu as besoin d'eux pour
être des tirés de jeux autour de sabonis
autour de fox pour la libérer de
l'espace dessous est ce que enfin lequel
des 2 correspond plus à un trop s'il
potentiellement tout elle shooter voilà
alors c'est une seconde à part les
chiites et cetera mais voilà c'était
pour les besoins de la tacc aujourd'hui
c'est une très bonne question hugues
par mois déjà du shooting jadida et vie
je vais je vais mettre ses forces et
faiblesses en attendant comme ça on aura
la présentation qui peuvent pas obligé
de le faire pour chaque joueur mais par
mois précisément du shooting steak à
bien regarder les préférences motrices
catch and shoot tout ça du joueur ouais
ouais parce que c'est un jour dont le
shoot et l e le point clé
il sort d'une première saison où qui du
côté donc de pure audio les polars
makers ou le tir est pas pas incroyable
alors qu lice il était réputé pour son
tir on le voit en championnat u19
capable de mettre des cartons mais de
façon assez régulière donc on se pose
vraiment la question et cette année elle
est le tir voit un mec qui sur le lancer
franc et des difficultés
on voit un mec qui dans le catch and
shoot est vraiment excellent avec un
gros volume est en fait qu on regarde un
petit peu de détails on voit que c'est
un joueur qui adore sortir des écrans
c'est un mec il le fait très bien qu'ils
se rééquilibre très rapidement dans
l'axé du panier qui est très à l'aise du
coup pas déclencher catch and shoot qui
peut finir fans chaîne mais qui peut
finir comme je le dis dans des systèmes
les mâles sont prêtes le
repositionnement est intelligent il voit
que tu as ton coéquipier on va dire la
fox qui part en rêve dans l'axé du
panier et ben lui il va les prendre la
ligne de passe la plus intéressante donc
revenir à 45 degrés par contre c'est un
twitter qu'ils montrent des difficultés
dans la création des espaces donc dans
tout ce qui est la clope et qui a des
difficultés sur le tir à l'arrêt soit
avec pas justement que poser des
dribbles soit aux lancers francs donc là
dessus va y avoir du travail à faire
maintenant côté sacramento tu as deux
créateurs balle en main fox et sabonis
qui regarde beaucoup le jeu tu peux
avoir un jeu avec ivy qui secourt de
partout par ses qualités athlétiques qui
peut que tu es sortir tir et être à
l'aise là dessus et dans une sombre unit
pourquoi pas comme disait si tu donnes
le ballon parce que c'est un très bon
driver tu t'es tu tu développes sont
tous leur game au fur et à mesure et
john mitchell à côté pour un peu si tous
les électeurs parce que david michel
était quand même un très bon créateur
niveau n 6 ap lors donc pour moi la
suite voulu tirer de la compatibilité du
développement ça marche très très bien
alors nous avons les nous sommes
internationaux comme vous le savez
envergure donc le scouting report est
écrit en anglais puisque c'est notre
québécois ben qui s'en est chargé et y
met le shooting en verre comme vous le
voyez shooting side dans les points
forts de chennai vie
évidemment ses points forts et ses
points forts qui saute aux yeux c'est
ses capacités athlétiques il va très
vite que ce soit nord-sud et est-ouest
même vers le haut il est plutôt il est
plutôt assez rapide et voilà les descend
à travailler le under
hugues aurait donc rajouter leur la
création pour soi ben là mis un petit
peu mais la création et donc ce midrange
se shootant sortie dream et en point
faible il met effectivement notre flore
général ce que ce que moi j'avais appelé
quand je quand on avait fait notre
premier une premier big board pour
l'instant je trouve qu'il n'a pas toutes
les vitesses de jeu il sait jouer vite
il s'est joué très vite et c'est
peut-être pas joué
moyens vite 30 mans
simon je te voyais beaucoup hocher la
tête
j'ai l'impression que le lead et te
plaît
alors l'idée me plaît le profil
commandeur en fait ce qui est bien ce
que permettrait donc de grave c'est un
mec comme à evian cats a des retombées
sur un modèle où tu as de nouveau ce
truc à trois têtes trois arrières qui en
avait au moment de bettié d'halliburton
fox et on a vu c'était soi-disant au
niveau du site et/ou compliqué que ça
marchait quand même pas mal et que ça
permettait à la liberté de briller ce
qu'on a remarqué aussi c'est que fox
était quand même meilleur une fois kathy
barton est parti
ça c'est en gros un pour aller vite mais
voilà mais que les trois fonctionner
bien qu est que collectivement l'équipe
avait sans doute un plafond là dessus
sur les deux dernières assez élevé
franchement à heavy est pas du tout le
même profil caliber skalli bertone mais
pourrait retrouver on va dire dans
l'utilisation le temps de jeu etc c'est
là où est le 2 le schéma de jeu allait
bertone avait commencé sur le banc et au
fur et à mesure a vite fait son trou en
montrant que le fit on s'en fout il
méritait de jouer de finir les matches
et être dans le cinq et c'est
maintenant il ya quand même quelque
chose qui me gêne profondément avec ivy
et c'est pas de sa faute c'est juste que
il est très redondant avec fox et mitch
est très très redondant je trouve dans
le sens où c'est pas
c'est pas à cinq je trouve que c'est moi
un profil intelligent on va dire
qu'halliburton qui peut du coup
complètement modeler son jeu et se dire
bon en attendant vaut mieux que je joue
trois que pas du tout et quand je suis
dans le cinq et je vais me débrouiller
je vais savoir faire je pense que c'est
fondamentalement il n'est pas capable de
faire ça et son jeu le permet pas et je
trouve surtout que il a amassé 2
deux shoots et de peut-être de variété
dans sa façon de scorer pour ne pas être
nommé en 2006 à des fox qui sont un peu
des petits arrières avec un shoot
correct voilà pas élite et cette
capacité pas content à jouer vite à à
bourdonner comme ça autour de sap à dix
postes de haut et a alterné un mélange
de coupes de shoot à mi distance et de
moments où eux-mêmes vont relayer dans
leur jeu par la passe une première passe
de sabonis sais pas si j'ai été très
clair mais moi et en gros à liffré
exactement pareil parce que si c'est
pour le mettre dans un coin je suis pas
si sûr qu'après sur les ailes et où il
est il est là il soit mis en valeur
c'est pour ça je pense vous pensé venir
que sharp al'avantage d'être un fit un
peu plus
[Musique]
comment dire comment trouver le bon
terme un feat potentiellement plus
intéressant
quelle vie et un court terme je suis
c'est là où je rejoins la réflexion
votre vie je pense qu'elle est vraiment
entre ces deux joueurs et qu'après de
façon à part d'être sharp et franchement
je suis content qu'on sera tous ensemble
parce que j'arrive pas à trancher seule
sur le choix des deux j'arrive pas à me
dire je n'arrive pas seul à avoir là
parce que la vie me paraît plus un pari
moins risqués me paraît un joueur tout
de suite plus performant que sharp qui
est parce que notamment ben voilà il a
pas joué ici quoi donc c'est emmerdant
pour l'évaluer mais par contre sharp me
paraît plus complémentaire est pas moins
talentueux pas moins talentueux chap pas
moins talentueux part d'ombré compris
qu'albi est plus complémentaire à
mitchell et fox
il ya cette question de la
complémentarité et donc la question la
valeur de son effectif qui rentrent en
ligne de compte si effectivement comme
tu le dit et
on va commencer par ça lui mais est-ce
que effectivement il est redondant avec
fox et mitchell par rapport à ce qu'on
connaît de ses joueurs par rapport aux
systèmes pour les optimiser et ensuite
aux livres est-ce que c'est pas risquer
de draft et ce joueur si on nous dit
qu'il est redondant
est-ce que c'est pas risquer par rapport
à la valeur de diar en stock ce qui
aujourd'hui est une vraie valeur de
trade de qui tu vas pouvoir
éventuellement tirer de la valeur si si
tu as envie de construire autour de
quelqu'un d'autre
est-ce que c'est pas risquer d'abord
d'abord pub sur la redondance entre al
djanadi et
tas de mecs qui font très vite c'est
vrai je pense que je n'avais eu plus de
valeur loin du ballon parce qu'il a plus
souvent joué loin du ballon et que lui
ça va pas le gêner de le faire il l'a
fait
avec claudio il a fait muet c'est un
encadrement familial la maman et coach
anciennement coach nba puis maintenant
cet entretien bien maintenant qu'on
tienne 6 et qui va le remettre dans le
droit chemin qui va le dire tu fermes ta
bouche et tu fais ce qu'il faut faire
pour développer
sa par rapport à son style de jeu il est
conscient de ses faiblesses il est très
clair il n'a pas peur de dire là dessus
je suis pas bon la larve où souvent on a
en un terreau du jour leur point fort en
disant ouais mais je fais très très bien
ça tu as vu il dit
mon flotteurs mon mi-distance une
version individuelle pour pour marquer
des points et faire jouer les autres
c'est suffisant je dois guide bossé là
dessus pour être un créateur balle en
main nba je pense que ya pas une
redondance en première année parce qu'il
va très vite comprendre comment il peut
jouer et que à terme si les kings
cherche un autre porteur de balle un
autre créateur qui sait ce qu'il doit
faire pour le devenir
olive toi tu est optimiste sur l'avenir
de fox de toute façon avec sacramento où
ça va un petit peu dépendent de ce qui
se passe pendant saison celle d'après
pas
bah oui oui je suis optimiste dans le
sens où que ça a quand même été enfin le
message était très clair que voilà
aujourd'hui à deux mecs intouchable à
sacramento c'est fox et sabonis tout le
reste autour là dessus éventuellement
éventuellement des vieux de mitchell on
peut encore discuter mais voilà fox et
sabonis aujourd'hui c'est les clés de
voûte c'est au tour de ceux autour de
quoi tu construis ton jeu comme l'a dit
comme l'a dit simon en début d'émission
voilà on essaie de construire quelque
chose autour d'eux si demain tu remets
en cause la place de fox dans le projet
ça va commencer et ça va commencer à
être compliqué c'est à dire que tu
repars un peu de zéro entre guillemets
tu que tu entames quelque chose de
nouveau
moi je pense que que fox il a le niveau
pour être au centre associé que sabonis
il a le niveau pour être au centre de ce
projet qu'on se construisent autour de
lui
maintenant je pense pas que l'arrivée
d'un rookie menacera sa place dans
l'immédiat je pense c'est quand même un
joueur qui est relativement créé
si je dis pas de bêtises il a à peine
commencé son contrat de cinq ans donc il
va lui restait qu'à thriller il a encore
quatre en deux il ya encore quatre ans
de contrat
il aura tout le temps de penser à la fin
de ces quatre ans il en a marre d'être
là sinon je veux quelque chose de plus
compétitifs ailleurs mais je pense que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on va faire en
sorte de le retenir le plus possible
donc il faut quand même drafté quelqu'un
qui
qui ne marche pas forcément sur ses
plates bandes
oui c'est ça c'est l'idée mais h après
on a vu que ça fait pas ça fait pas peur
à ma mère de draft est tout le temps sur
les mêmes postes il a draftés deux
années de suite sur les postes boehner
arrière donc lui valait s'il n'y a pas
de mes voyages toujours en cherchant une
espèce une espèce de complémentarité et
après si je sais pas si ce qu'il en
pense mais ce qu'est aujourd'hui voir
angie dan ellis en plus si demain on
voit que des danaïdes il est drafté sais
que ma mère pense qu'il est
complémentaire avec fox c'est panne il
pense que la terme il peut le remplacer
tu vois moi je pense je pense que mac
mais réfléchit comme ça aujourd'hui je
pense que que fox et voilà comme j'ai
dit à l'heure c'est sa pierre angulaire
avec sabonis situe draft est un gars
c'est que tu penses que ça va marcher à
côté de suuns
simon sur le sur le côté
psychologie de cette équipe des kings
quels profils y manque parce que jaden
avis c'est un profil très intelligentes
capables de nous y voilà de s'adapter
vaincu qui vient du monde etc
on a l'impression que ces deux dernières
années on a surtout drafté des dégâts un
peu sur avec un bon caractère et tous
les gains peu gentil quoi peut-être pas
dire mais c'était c'était avant
maintenant
qu'est ce que tu penses qu'ils qu'elle
quel genre de caractère irait bien
est-ce qu'il faut un leader à cette
équipe et ce qu'il faut un super second
couteau qu est ce qu il faut
ça dépend en fait c'est comment dire il
ya ta question sous-entend une autre
question un pardon de commencer comme ça
mais est ce que ce joueur c'est celui
que tu vas drafté ou est ce que c'est à
terme tu as un plan de tu vises un autre
joueur est suivi un échange et c'est
parce que tu veux tu trouves que ton
vrai noyau sabonis et fox ont peut-être
pas le temps non plus pour être cette
équipe qui a un cycle de trois endroits
elle pour aller en play-offs d'attendre
qu'un gamin de 18 ans
deviennent all star
et je pense que et c'est pour ça que
c'est très compliqué le cas des kings ce
que l'on sait pas exactement quel est le
plan de magna s'il en a d'ailleurs et
tout mais et c'est pour ça que dès le
début aussi on savait que l'équipe c'est
d'être intéressant il est quasiment
emmerder d'être monté à la monterie
parce que sinon ils drafté cet qui
gagnerait ou un ailier qui était vite
pépère et voilà et là en fait il ya une
espèce d'opportunités où il doit se
démerder pour faire le bon choix soit
tout de suite parce que je fais jackpot
avec toi en outre hijja dernier vie est
vraiment un espèce de tonneaux bonne
mutuelle est en fait sa clique je vais
rentrer un bond dans des comparaisons
pas forcément hasardeuse mais j'essaie
de la limite est schématiser remet donc
à un arrière petit tonique scoreur etc
qui se donne deux ou via une super
mentalité qui effectivement c'est ça
c'est hyper important je trouve quand
même de préciser dans un encadrement
donc papa maman sport le sport de haut
niveau c'est leur quotidien c'est pas
juste en plus c'est leur quotidien dont
le gamin grandi là dedans et où
j'imagine qu'effectivement il est
conditionné pour pas faire chier s'il
joue pas exactement comme il veut enfin
c'est ce genre de truc parfait
maintenant
pour en revenir à ta question plus
simplement et tout
c'est quand même effectivement matière à
prouver je m'appuie sur ce qu'il me
disait que draft et ça paraît logique de
draft et ivy puisqu'il a déjà travaillé
mais shell et halliburton si on remonte
même c'est pas lui mais il ya quand même
le spect la grave dont site on se
rappelle qu'en plus cette espèce de truc
on prend pas don si tu parce que c'est
redondant dans l'utilisation pas dans le
profil mais c'est redondant et fox je
pense pas que dans la vie va devenir
dont seach sinon on arrête tout le merci
pour merci pour tous pour sète ce moment
passé ensemble et on a effectivement ont
tiré le gros lot et et tout ce qui se
passe avec ton site fera oublier mais
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
mackler peut s'en [ __ ] et on a vu que
c'est des conneries en fait c'est un
joueur qui devient hyper fort tu t'en
fous comme au rang de sa draft et c'est
tout donc elle vit n'est pas et pas du
tout un pari par rapport à charge moi je
vous dis toujours les deux je suis
désolé mais j'arrive pas à parler de la
sent tout de suite évoqué ce que je
trouve que ça marche comme ça
mais moi j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'il ya un plan de magna qui avait pas
une urgence non plus mais qui a une
volonté
ivy sera bon assez vite et dans 2 3 ans
tu est effectivement très bon et la
pièce qui permet d'être en playoffs de
trois ans de suite avec cette espèce on
aurait donc un noyau fox a vida john
mitchell sabonis et éventuellement la
dent année 10 qui s'est développée on
est d'accord
ok ben moi c'est un plan sympa evans
mais je pense qu'il ya un plan peut-être
plus rapide et plus stable ou c# lepic
et swatch art devient lui-même une
espèce de sous pas le george mais un 19
20 ans 21 ans en sixième homme et est
quand même à danton un objectif
d'accrocher les play-offs soit arrive à
monter assez vite là sur le potentiel de
sharp en l'accrochant harrison barnes à
un autre pic etc et tu vas chercher ton
délié créateur défensif et c'est ton
vrai free and i kass border la jeune
star est à ton espèce de truc sabonis
fox je sais pas qui où là il ya vraiment
aucune discussion t/t tout le temps aux
play-offs 7/8 voilà on va laisser poser
d'ici l'e3 l'ajouter match et se blesse
pas
pour résumer tout le club du bac je vais
le faire je pense quand même que le plan
de fox le plan de magna c'est celui-là
ok
c'est cool la redondance parce que on
oublie un truc à libertad il a pris en
12 parce que c'était une évidence et
émergents dispo
suis pas sûr que sinon il aurait
peut-être évité au fils teints et des
excellents arrêts tout je suis pas sûr
qu'il ya quand même des trucs comme ça
et moi je pense me voilà pour finir le
mais peut-être qu'il y aura une évidence
peut-être que pour lui et jada naïve
isra levy dans 104 et qu'il avait emmené
son board
je pense surtout que ça va être à vie
s'ils ont fini cette réflexion un peu
commune est comme ça moi je pourrais
prendre la parole parce que sharp
célibat risques et c# avait eu des
matchs de cfa tachibana je pense qu'il
prendrait sharp ne serait ce que pour un
simple truc c il est un peu plus grand
il est un peu plus longue il peut mieux
défendre des postes extérieurs
1 il peut peut-être joué 3 et voilà et
on serait pas là à déblatérer pendant
longtemps en fait mais ces charges c'est
hyper risque et je trouve et je suis pas
sûr que mc nerfs et le et le envie de
prendre un ris comme ça parce qu'ils
veulent payer très cher kouassi charpy
ces marches une boucle au bout de deux
mois il edouard
parlons parlons de sheridan sharp avance
à un petit message pour vous remercier
de votre activité dans le tchat et si
vous n'êtes pas encore abonné goût
puisque comme ça vous recevrez les
notifs dès qu'on passera en live ou dès
qu'on sortira une vidéo il n'a encore
pas mal à sortir notamment des portraits
des portraits de draft et
potentiellement assez haut hugues on
parle de shannon sharpe je sais que
c'est pas ton joueur préféré à évaluer
puisque je n'ai pas pu voir un énorme
échange sera en deux matches
néanmoins
par rapport à ce qu'a dit simon et ce
qui peut jouer 2,3
selon toi à court terme puisque c'est
comme ça qu'on va le développer quand
même
est-ce qui peut défendre correctement
les extérieurs sur ce que tu as vu voilà
les deux questions qui se pose
est ce qui est ce qui peut jouer de
trois oui il a le gabarit physique
parfait il a la taille il a l'envergure
c'est un athlète diouf verticalement
parlant tout du moins c'est un joueur
qu'il a dominé le niveau lycéens par là
par la puissance parce qu'il était déjà
encore loupé donc tu peux très vite
l'intérêt dans un stade fait de bien et
ce qui peut défendre les et
le physique tu te dire que oui mais il a
jamais eu envie de le faire que ce soit
au niveau high school pasqua il sculpte
déjà personnes des fonds c'est un
championnat un peu un peu freestyle il
n'a pas joué dans un énorme programme
lycéens et les matchs qu'il a joué
contre les gros programme lycéens on les
a pas vues qui sont pas accessibles donc
ça c'est un problème est au niveau de la
team canada parce qu'il a fait
le cese canada détient déjà 3 3 4 ans il
n'avait pas défendu non plus les outils
il les a peut-être plus pour les post 2
3 parce qu'il ya un manque de ya un
manque de mobilité au sol axe panier
panier en explosivité et latéralement un
petit peu
plus tôt les postes de 3 kg en deux et
après pour aller sur la jetée d'être sur
la complémentarité encore une fois
est-ce que pas pour le propos de simon
pour maintenir pour moi ce que j'en
comprends et je suis pas expert king
c'est un mec qui prend pas le risque qui
joue qui aime bien les dates avancées
encore une fois qu'ils aiment bien les
les profils un peu un peu cf mentalement
un peu cf dans le jeu il ya chez des
sharks et les reverse exact ça y est
même beaucoup aux moines il y est pas
allé il a très peu parlé donc ce
scénario est fortement improbable sauf
si dans le work atteint divialle qu'ils
ont fait
ça c'est il ya eu un coup de coeur
énorme et que finalement macneil a
projeté des plots à la place il a mis
des joueurs nba dans sa tête mentalement
il a dit ouais c'est aussi bien que te
donne agit ou d'autres
après il ya eu le temps qu'il fait du
coup
d'asile azilazian dont parle du coup
interrogations en tête bête mais pas si
bête pourquoi ce mec-là il est aussi
haut dans la draft et aujourd'hui alors
personne n'a entendu parler lui que
personne n'est capable de voir des
matchs est ce que est ce que c'est
suffisant d'être très très fort au lycée
pour exploser un taux de 4,5 de draft
aujourd'hui quoi
déjà qu'ils interloquant quoi déjà déjà
donc là le sur le
scouting report qui à l'écran on peut
voir des qualités évidentes
de shenzhen charges qui sont quand même
très projetable en nba c'est à dire que
le tir un joueur qui tire à quasiment
40% à 3 points alors qu'il fait que du
pool og alors certes c'est la ligne
lycéenne c'est quand même impressionnant
c'est un joueur
kg pas combien ça fait en cm 49 pouce de
détente sèche
après 1 m enfin ses plus hauts de dix
centimètres que le premier du combined
genge combined donc c'est un gars qu'à
la tête auxerre c'est un gars qui est
qui qui shoot à 3 points donc forcément
ça fait ça fait saliver deuxièmement les
scot ils l'ont j'ai joué depuis son
dernier match à l'escale qui l'ont vu
jouer ils sont allés à kentucky ils ont
discuté avec john calipari ils l'ont vu
ils l'ont mis dans des oppositions
forcément enfin ils ont vu dans des
oppositions enfin même si effectivement
son conseiller essaye de le cacher
un maximum pour préserver sa cote en
tout cas c'est ce qui a l'air de se
dessiner au niveau de la stratégie
les lesca août les scripts nba ils font
leur boulot ils vont au plus près voilà
ils vont creuser pour avoir de
l'information pour aller voir des
enfants qui pour aller peut-être voire
des oppositions même ces deux
oppositions contre des gars qui seront
pas drafté mais chez lynch par pilar
besoin il sait qu'il a besoin j'espère
qu'il ya besoin de jouer pour continuer
à progresser et
les entraînements à kantigui et steve
selon ce qu'on a pu lire pendant la
saison voilà ça c'est là ça c'est ma
réponse à ta question pour relancer
hughes
est ce que la projection en sièges
est meilleur que la projection lycée
defacto
ça permet de comprendre face à des
gabarits physique un peu plus développée
quand même ont surtout entre un freshman
et un senior à 4 en 2d physique sachant
qu'il ya des conférences majeures
notamment la ici si vous tapez des gros
bestiaux qui peuvent faire une bière et
ça te permet aussi de vous avoir un
système de jeu qui est quand même
souvent qu'au lycée will be c'est à ces
patchs et matiz et mais je défends pas
trop tu envoies le bal - l'opposé tu
cours tu cours tu as peut-être un pick
n'roll tu tire et ça et en plus de ça
comme tu as dit l'a pas joué depuis pas
vu jouer depuis un an un an et demi il
se passe énormément de choses en un an
un an et demi peut être un facteur non
neuf mois de octobre il fait son dernier
match ouais dit c'est ouais
du côté de gpu z comme passe non je dis
n'importe quoi
est ce que vous avez d'autres questions
saint
[Musique]
ouen dream city christiane s'est jamais
laissé glisser faudrait à la new man u
pour pour nous éclairer
simon simon au livre vous avez des
questions sur celle qui donne est ce que
vous êtes d'autres interrogations sur
son éventuel fitou sur la question
principale effectivement sinon tu le
soulignes s est celle du risque c'est
celle du risque est il pour vous pour
moi c'est encore plus risqué et paradon
c'est pas pour trash et les kings mais
ils n'ont pas un historique de
développement des joueurs
extraordinaires les joueurs qui
réussissent chez les kings c'est les
joueurs qui sont déjà prêts quoi
c'est ça j'allais comment on peut
résumer ça dans un an c'est pas parce
que
c'est un joueur malheureusement parce
que je pense qu'il a un talent fou même
si la page 26 mai il ya quand même
quelque chose qui fait qui fait un petit
goûter au niveau de la faculté de la
facilité de se mettre là parce qu'il
faut aller voir effectivement on peut
pas avoir deux matches nc de sharp aider
pour cause mais on peut voir des matchs
odyssée d'autres mecs et du coup moi je
les fais parce que sinon de la question
en est simple mais comment on peut
imaginer sharp ont initié tout bas c'est
dur à dire il va pas jouer à qui on
comparerait tout on sait pas mais on
peut du coup voir des mecs qui ont fait
45 ou deux mais au même âge et je vous
jure je les fais un peu importe des
profils
semaine on va dire ces dernières années
ben en fait tu te rends compte que sharp
pourrait scinder l'ircam a pratiquement
parlant je parle juste de mes fans a
facilité la gestuelle et où il a quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre des talents
vraiment vraiment supérieur juste au
niveau quand tu le regardes à l'oeil
quoi là on parle pas des stats avancer
tout ça et tout mais je vous jure je
pense que je vois aussi pardon quand on
voit des images de chats
moi ça me fait penser on va dire c'est
pas loin de ce qu'on disait et la hype
rappelez vous quand il parce qu'il avait
joué à cannes turquie de wilkins par
exemple il est plus petit un peu cher
mais aussi en termes de détente de trucs
comme c'est à dire
quand ça se parle on est
tu regarde par exemple je trouve un
danser sur ses dix années ça cette unité
quasiment de l'équipe obama je crois oui
en terme de free qu'athlétique quoi et
de facilités pour un mec qui va jouer en
gros 2 3 en nba
mais c'est pas pour les kings parce que
c'est trop risqué c'est un mec qui doit
se développer au show qui va qui va sans
doute prendre des années en plus je suis
pas si sûr comme il est et il n'est pas
immense ans et papa de changements plus
on était entaillée tout
la différence entre lui et lui même en
terme de gabarit et tous et pas assez je
trouve monstrueuse c'est pas un ailier
avec une potentialité de jouer intérieur
sharp c123 voilà c'est pas ou peut-être
éventuellement petit minutes en quatre
étoiles et c'est là où en fait
fondamentalement si elle vie prend un
peu de muscles tout ça et tout vu de
gabarre excès bon bah ce sera à peu près
les mêmes postes en faites pas on ira
sur beaucoup de leur temps de jeu ça
remplira les mêmes occupations de poste
2 voir on est 3 selon les matches un peu
tout je pense qu'on est d ailleurs voilà
et aviapartner vachement de garantie et
avis en pêche pas ces jeux olympiques
stratégie mais l'autre ce truc que à
terme ils te permet d' ici même dès
février de dire ben voilà en fait lui ou
me tiennent par exemple si la vie est
vraiment très fort et il estime qu'en
fait mais tu es tu les tue juxtapose à
harrison barnes et là tu commences à
avoir un truc tu peux faire un trait
trade center a un je ne sais pas si
c'est dans l'histoire récente en rookie
qui travaillait au bout de six mois
halliburton en 2e année par les kings
sur wii non mais cette année l'été
prochain voir la news après tu peux
donner mon la part n'aura pas trop de
valeur mais tu as une pièce vraiment un
ascète les samak nerfs on sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils drafté tout parce
que voilà mais on sait on l'a vu s'il
estime qu'il peut avoir un retard pour
un rookie alors que toute la
twittosphère adore mais que luigi ouais
mais je m'en fous c'est pas ça me disent
c'est pas 26 tous les soirs je le fais
le trade il l'a fait d'accord enfin il
me dit que s'il faut il faut transformer
ivy en
autoporteur et plein de piques parce
qu'en fait c'est mieux pour l'équipe
tout de suite et tout son objectif peur
etc sur mon maître nadjar quoi autant
porter et où on va mais il le fera sa
manière si il estime que l ouest et hi
fi ne brise pas sa stratégie par rapport
au choix de sharp tout en étant un truc
qu sûr et pour son poste et là tout de
suite cette saison parce que je pense
qu'elle vit et ça on arrête tout accord
sera immédiatement plus
performants gens savaient plus utile en
tout cas sur des parcs nvier que sharp
qui risque d'être vraiment perdu et de
vraiment pas comprendre ce qui lui
arrive pendant au moins trente quarante
matches je pense dans le temps qui passe
qui l'a jamais joué en fac alors qu'albi
je pense que ça va prendre cinq matches
et le mec on va déjà voir que compte des
bourgs adverse en fait sur des séquences
il peut faire la diff ça je pense djédjé
n'diaye sophomore et effectivement il a
il y a plus de matches au compteur et
plus
sa maman et je ne pense pas que ce n'est
pas le cas de chypre en soi que en
espèces de mètres qui a la balle pendant
des séquences défunte 12eme carton des
trucs comme ça dans des back to back à
la con tu des pistols et où moi je pense
qu'il peut il peut déjà vite faire du
star n'est bien sûr mais en plus il faut
pas oublier ceux ci
après je te file à la parole donnée mais
il faut pas oublier que
jaden avis quand il a la balle déjà la
patte tant que ça ayew et
a perdu c'était n'importe quoi
il a pas beaucoup d espace enfin les
terrains sont pas sont pas toujours
aussi grand qu'en nba
pas toujours des shooteurs enfin il ya
même jamais jamais des shooteurs de même
niveau un siècle billets ça n'existe pas
des équipes comme ça donc
effectivement
avec de l'espace avec sa vitesse même si
il n'a pas encore toutes les nuances de
jouer le pick and roll met le mec dans
son dos ensuite ré accéléré que
tu le fais jouer sur des matchs de
saison régulière sur tous voilà ça
défend un peu moins dur sur demi terrain
quand même il ya plus de transition
aussi évidemment qui va être efficace
sans pour moi
une tu voulais rajouter quelque chose se
passe ces surcharges poésie où les way
c'est sûr charme dans le contexte
pourquoi est-ce qu'on me les gens me
posent beaucoup de questions aussi
pourquoi top 5 pourquoi toutes ces
cassures et aussi c'est parce que chez
dunlop c'est peut-être le seul mec une
fois que tu passes en gros bonne quiero
et peut-être jabbari smith qui peut
prendre le ballon et créer de la tacc
pour lui-même et le faire bien en place
et on est une draft qu'on ne l'a dit il
ya peu-être potentialités il ya peu de
joueurs qui voulaient très très bien et
qui se créent leur propre tir ce qui est
peut-être le style is le plus cher dans
le top cinq top-10 de la draft et
sheldon serbie peut le faire en 2023 il
y aura peut-être plus de mecs et du coup
un gars qui se serait se profile un peu
underground cachet
sera un peu plus dévalorisé la lui et de
la rareté donc il ya l'excitation ya le
corps il yal intrigue et à la rareté du
profil qui font que on a tous les
ingrédients réunis pour le draft est
très très très très haut
je reviens juste au kick sur la capacité
de créer son shoot on va dire moi
j'imagine à cinq secondes de la fin
d'une possession un peu à l'arraché
contre à ivy là aussi où pas pour toi
ou 1 par rapport à sharp là dessus est
vraiment super a rêvé il n'a pas peur de
la fronde a pas peur de les prendre mais
il crée moins d espace dans lost un
changement de vitesse steinbach cette
step voilà il peut te prendre des
tickets il peut amener un pic déclenché
derrière mais il va pas te faire iso
fixation postaux aux obstacles se
déclenche dessus ça il est moins à
l'aise dessus pour l'instant
en fait john hayes vie c'est un athlète
au trait horizontal très qui qui qui va
aller au contact mais qui va supporter
le contact et du coup on va créer de
l'espace grâce à ça mais pour se créer
son tir chez dunlop c'est plus un
athlète de bâton temps parlait tout à
l'heure mais de faciliter de fluidité un
joueur on n'a pas l'impression mais en
fait il va on n'a pas l'impression qu'il
va vite mais en fait il va arriver à
freiner très fort monté sur un seul pas
monter tout gainer déroulé son tir c'est
ça et il ya un truc qui me
qui me ferait quand même peur à ne pas
drafté charte parce qu'on en verra ça et
prendre avis c'est qu'il ya un détail 20
passés par détails mais y'a un pour un
aspect pardon du jeu de sharp
effectivement j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'a pas c'est cette espèce de truc à la
un peu à la john brandon va dire cette
expérience est pas de changer tout mais
ce truc tu es vrai vrai sur mana tout
seul juste d'un coup par la part le côté
c'est l'enchaînement tout simple en fait
mais de dribble entre les jambes et un
truc
espèce de ce truc de joueurs de
rencontrer en fait tout simplement pour
le résumer cette espèce d'instinct
qu'ont les joueurs de la contraint à la
joe johnson fait tout ce qu'on veut et
où vraiment ce truc qui fait que ça on
le sait
c'était en janvier 20 ans avec cette
connerie tu vois ce talon la pure parce
que ça restera toujours été un poil plus
long que ton adversaire direct et ont
deux shoots tu fait ficelle bassa
et ivy
en fait le prince d'avis et que je sais
pas si on tient potentiellement un
espèce de mai qu'elle adorait mitchell
où effectivement malgré le côté petit
gabarit et où le mec est tellement on va
dire
le dosage agressivité intelligence à
prendre les intervalles tout ça fait
qu'en fait ça score sans aucun problème
ou si d'un coup ça va être un peu un
vrai frein parce que
comment dire bien sûr on pourra toujours
traitées soit fox soit mitchell et le
garder soit le trade et lui et tout mais
s'arrête un autre frein aussi pour les
équipes nba parce que attention en fait
c'est du coup c'est pas déjà mort hante
il n'est pas assez athlétiquement
dominant pour devenir à 25 points par
match un esprit tout est un coup d qui
joue des matchs un pied en fait son
potentiel baisse par rapport aux
commandes au fond tu as même que
représente le pit iv et la petite est
drafté et là on en reviendrait donc le
presque tout le truc mais avec ce que
des élus au début qu'il faudrait
drafté presque maintenant pour dire une
autre équipe voilà prenez en fait un
siècle pitt cate où est ce que je veux
dire qu'elle vire en
commande à 5 ans en jouant montre que ok
ça va être un super joueur mais en fait
ce sera pas une star alors que sharp
peut être un potentiel beaucoup
pouvez-vous plomb à développer mais par
contre dès le début dès ses premiers
dribbles il ya un espèce de frissons un
peu comme ce qui avait amené kobe dès
ses premiers dribbles vraiment un truc
ultime quoi c'est le seul truc qui me
ferait
ch a dit résister comme au moment de
voter mais vous savez de valider
sa intérêt à pas devient le nouveau kobe
parce que sinon on va dire
mais ce n'est pas une question pour
revenir sur ivy et après je donne la
parole à olives sur sur sharp quoique on
a peu entendu là-dessus on entend la
comparaison jam au ranch davy elle
arrive elle est surtout avec les
performances récentes de jenn grant etc
quelles sont les différences au même
niveau de cars et
les deux projections augmenter de deux
hauts fourneaux qui vont arriver à
granby avec le même âge
les quatre principales battu lazio tout
à l'heure c'est le changement de vitesse
aussi c'est que marraine qui va très
vite me seck se stopper et du coup il
s'est créé son nez car ils avaient plus
de touchés dans le petit périmètre
changer mieux de direction y avait plus
de variations dans cette vitesse et
deuxièmement il voyait plus de choses
jamais ton voile athlètes on voi le mec
qui part qui donne qu'il ya beaucoup de
lectures de passes très compliqué de
deux de manipulation visuel vraiment de
gestion de l'écran avec c'est beaucoup
d'espacé et c'est pas évident pour
l'instant tapas donc et arrive il le dit
très très bien et dejagah diamètre
médias mauvaise est un mec crémieux de
l'écart que moi qui freine plus qui voit
mieux donc moi c'est ça que je dois
bosser et c'est vraiment ce qui
différencie les deux étaient donnés vit
il ce qui l'aurait cette palette là il
aurait ce ce pool a piloté ce création d
car il aurait cette gestion de son tempo
on en parlait comme le premier choix en
fait et donc c'est ça qui manque
actuellement à ce pour être dans la
caste de tueur termes de potentialités
certains en parlent comme mon premier
choix et
que ce soit ici en france aux états unis
olive
sheldon chaque je reviens vers le vert
vers lui un vers toi pour lui plutôt
qu'est ce que tu en penses sur ce compte
a décrit alors on sait que c'est flou
mais sur la potentielle animation
offensive et défensive des kinski et
comment il s'insère en première année
comment lui donne du temps de jeu comme
on lui donne des tirs aussi
comment ils s'insèrent dans donc je sais
pas c'est pas évident on dit parce que
de secours y avait des cris j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même un
joueur qui a beaucoup besoin d'avoir la
balle moi si je me trompe si du coup
quelqu'un qui est capable de pas mal
créé pour lui-même qui va être capable
de prendre des tirs en fin de possession
même de jouer des un contre un et où
je sais pas comment ça s'insère dans une
attaque aujourd'hui j'ai centré sur un
big man honnêtement je suis pas assez
analyse du jeu pour pour le titre est
ici mais
mais j'aime beaucoup ce que pourrait
apporter chez les hommes charles dans le
sens où voilà oui pour apporter ce petit
éclair de génie ce petit côté flashy et
dont on aura un peu besoin n'aura pas
besoin sacramento qu'on arrête un peu de
foot notre gueule de dire qu'on est une
équipe de la campagne qu'on arrose qu on
a zéro flots et que truc comme ça tu
vois j'y revois la confrérie contre une
équipe un peu site afoc sabonis qui
jouent bien ensemble tu mets un shedden
sharp à côté qui sans être exceptionnel
fait des petits highlights par ci par là
commence à marquer des points machin
montre qui six corps est un levier pâte
à utah potentiellement une équipe l'icpa
c'est tout moi si c'est le côté ces deux
côtés que j'aime bien avec celle de
sharp au delà du au delà du shit
potentiels ces voix l'a
amené à mener un petit peu de
potentiel star en fait voilà ce côté là
toi tu es toi tu veux retrouver redonner
redonner du sexy à sacramento quoi tu
veux que ça redevienne
un lieu attractif pour
les fans et le joueur
je pense ouais bah moi c'est ce dont
j'ai envie je pense qu'un joueur comme
ça il peut te plies peu d'apporter ce
truc là je dis pas que je ne veux pas le
faire mais si tu donnes charb
potentiellement 6,6 à petit chez qui il
envoie les mêmes highlights qui faisait
owni c'est effectivement là on va
commencer à dire les kings ils ont ils
tiennent un truc incroyable voilà après
après voilà comment comme ça a été dit
tout à l'heure voilà c'est un pic - sexe
ça ressemble pas trop à ce que fait ma
clair en termes de draft depuis qu'il
est arrivé
sans parler des mots coulent à la
première semaine après la loterie ça
fait à peu près moitié ivy moitié chars
dans les mots qu'aujourd'hui si
quasiment que du ahly
je sais pas quelle est la raison à cela
est voilà c'est juste voilà j'ai
l'impression qu'il a un petit peu glissé
dans l'estiment
dsk au dessous des dirigeants ces
derniers temps celui non c'est vrai on
entendait parler beaucoup en top 5 et en
a qui disent parce qu'il n'a pas joué au
con ban qui a fait que des pros d'aix je
vérifie si ces féroces et récemment par
un parent dirigeants je peux dire inédit
avec les flics qui ronge et en gros
qu'en gros il avait rien prouvé que on
sait pas ce qu'il foutait top 5 et c'est
non ça prouve quand même que voilà il ya
même si il est considéré comme un gros
potentiel et où il ya quand même il ya
quand même des dirigeants et de pied qui
croient pas en lui quoi c'est son doigt
d'un dirigeant que je n'ai pas en lien
avec son équipe de ce casting ou qui
avait complètement arrêté de suivre la
draft mais oui c'est un dirigeant a dit
ça est ce qu on a encore des choses à se
dire sur chars ivy est ce que vous
voulez qu'on choisisse maintenant
sur sharp encore plus que évident pour
finir ça concerne le 2 mai
je veux rebondir jusque jeudi olivier on
n'en a pas parlé mais je trouve qu'il ya
quand même un aspect psychologique au
fait que ce soit les kings qui soit 4 et
qui doit faire ce choix il ya l'aspect
sportif et tout ça mais je vous jure que
entre le trauma dont 6 et où vous
connaissez tous dans la physique les
l'histoire du chat de schrödinger où tu
sais l'état
c'est d'être instable en traitement ou
vivant et en gros tu es une expérience
qui permet de dire qu à l'instant t il
est mort ou vivant se piquent 4c
l'église disent qu'ils ont c'est le chat
il est vivant c'est je sais pas moi les
pistes en ce qu'ils ont le chat il est
vivant même s'il a peut-être un poil aux
pattes est tous et indiana le chagrine
en pleine santé celle des spurs évident
le chat et il est vivant c'est l'équipe
ne charrie les morts vous le savez ça
c'est
et comme on doit aussi nous représenter
un tout petit peu de l'appliquer des
fans des kinks tout ça et où il faut le
dire parce que on a peur en fait on est
une équipe je vous jure que là on le
voit nous on a c'est vrai licha on a le
sentiment prince william en est a depuis
confié compliquer at on en tournait à 6
son message dans ce truc sur globalement
mais sans que personne soit mais vous
voyez de on a on va chercher des mots
qu'on se parle on mafia on il ya des
petits moments où quelqu'un à bâtir pas
quand même qu'ils gagneraient machin est
tout il ya une conversation juste en
face du tout mais le sentiment principal
toutes ont peut-être pour un stage on
s'est fait chier on pique 4 c'est
important en fait on peut pas se
permettre de faire une connerie on est
des kings tout le monde nous regarde il
ya donc six acteurs écharpe il fait
flipper
c'est tout c'est un jeu moi je veux
juste faire ça avant de choisir béchard
qui fait flipper et
et en même temps parce qu'on revient au
tchad c'est non seulement une autre
équipe va donc le draft et parce que si
les kings ne prennent pas il va tomber
par exemple pistols ils vont ouvrir la
boîte chez tom sharpe est l'enfoiré ça
va devenir vince carter vous le savez ça
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un truc comme
ça qu'ils jouent dans ce pic des kicks
parce que et je vous jure je veux pas
faire ça mais juste pour rigoler mais la
dernière fois que les kings avait un
truc important sur une grave c'est celle
de son site ils ont fait n'importe quoi
ça va c'est 15 ans d'histoire et de
billets entre le trait de crayon enfin
ça a permis un trait de crayon de ton
site dont on va parler des années dont
si tu vas sans doute à la fin être un
des mecs qui va bousculer des histoires
de bergerot perdre d'histoire
lyon est en train enfin l'an dernier
c'est demain ki-moon plus de points 2
passes 3 en volume de toute la digue et
qui créent les chemises de points chauds
voilà donc nous quoiqu'il se passe il va
sans doute y avoir une dinguerie autour
de notre choix et c'est est ce que tu
sais alexandre des débuts et c'est vrai
je vais rester là dessus parce qu'en
plus on est une franchise qui a peur
donc il va pas vous il ya plein de
facteurs qui font que iris sans doute
d'avoir un vrai impact un dessin sur sa
droite et on va en parler très vite on
est en baisse c'est incroyable et on
oublie un truc moi je trouve c'est que
ça veut peut-être dire aussi que il va
avoir une dinguerie sur les trois duos
on a trop vite je crois évacuer le fait
que 1 2 3 c'est dans le marbre ces
seuils fait c'est parce que peut-être
qu'en fait oklahoma va te dirai
attendait hi fi on peut pas le laisser
passer on a des doutes sur un grain par
exemple et banque héros parce que si
cette épreuve après tous mes jeux on a
on est d'accord là dessus on a très vite
aussi dit à 2,3 ça c'est sûr à 100% donc
on n'a évoqué aucune aucun scénario là
dessus nous nous non là ce constat on le
répète on le répète à chaque on le
répète à chaque live pour nous pas grave
tu as 3 et très probablement même si
médiatiquement la l'air de l'être très
probablement que ça n'en est pas une
donc qu
est-ce que si un des 3 descend on le
pique obligatoirement
obligatoirement juste je sais pas dépend
peut-être une note 2 pour moi oui il
faut ce qu'il faut sans hésiter on va
parler de cette année john barry smith
pour moi we go
palau bonne quiero
dans le gpat peur on le joue avec je
pense que malgré le contexte kings et
les fêtes comme tu le dis la gare soit
sur eux qui une pression de résultat et
ou pas l'aumône qui revient pas de souci
pour lui là dessus c'est un mec qui est
très stable qui pourra se développer
n'importe quel contexte pourri mais la
relation bonne quéreux sabonis dans le
jeu lui qui est plus aussi demi terrain
avec fox moi j'aime pas
le potentiel il est plus élevé que les
autres donc go mais ça faut opter de
l'idée et nous faut que tu as un
coaching stuff qui sert et que tu as un
projet comme ça de développement donc
bonne pierrot c'est pas un choix évident
dont le dans la logique de jeu mais
sinon oui les trois et trois fouilles à
l'aimer citadine à tanger par louis
smith go
mais tu aimes pas sur des coraux pour
prendre quand même par exemple tu aimes
pas ces banques héros pour prendre
l'avis du coup moi je suis les kings je
prends bonne quiero mais ça veut dire
que dans ma tête
très rapidement fox et sabonis de vienne
pour moi bouge à bhl parce que je pense
que dans la banque de développement
je construis mieux au tour de bonneteau
je trouve que ça plus d'impact de jeu
que sabonis bonne quiero pour moi ça va
pas marcher sabonis bonne quéro ni
défensivement ni offensivement sur tous
les chantiers que tu as construction
indique bien défensivement surtout
défense ça c'est le scénario le plus
kings ça c'est le sénat le picking c'est
à dire qu'après avoir traité halliburton
la justification de traiter ok on a
changé le projet on est dans le projet
de montage c'est de rechange et de
projets à l'adresse suivante parce que
tu te sens vente heroes vi était obligé
de le prendre et ça c'est voilà
franchement je pense qu'olivier va
valider ce propos c'est le contexte
complètement complètement et je pense
que c'est encore plus flippant après la
loterie on se dit merde lepic 4 c'est
vraiment le jeu comme pour les raisons
que j'ai c'est à l'heure vous n'êtes pas
forcément vrai mais voilà le pic est
c'est un peu le pic piège dans le sens
où on avait un top3 plus ou moins défini
aujourd'hui s'il ya un mec qui glisse
c'est pareil c'est laisser le même deal
c est ce qu on le prend obligatoirement
il faut sauter dessus parce qu'il est
sorti du top 3 ou voilà il faut où on
reste sur notre notre scénario de départ
on choisit on choisit entre ivy écharpe
et encore une fois voilà si on rate un
mec qui qui sortent ils sentaient
potentiellement du top 3 et qui
fonctionne pas chez nous ça va être
trouvé les mêmes rengaines quand on fait
poster les hauts talons et c'est donc
forcément forcément rentrer dedans et
mettre tous les scénarios ça fait peur
si simon retrouve retranscrit très bien
le la pensée du groupe de discussion
qu'on entre fans des kicks et vraiment
il ya un sentiment de peur générale peu
importe le scénario quels qu'ils soient
trade draft quoi et c est toujours un
moyen pour nous que ça marche pas quoi
alors on va les faire un par un quand
même pour moi de chanter en grain elle
propose que les plus sûres d'assez loin
de cette draft par les garanties
défensives qui la porte je dis pas qui
sera all star jeudi king on est sûr
qu'il l'a il aura une production et un
impact sur l'équipe
c'est mon avis
non partagé sorte à g ici
jabbari
pour moi est moins sûr dans le ce qu'il
a montré au niveau du jeu en revanche
dans son éthique de travail dans ce que
dans la progression qu'il a eu du fait
qu'il a un an de moins aussi et du fait
que ben il fait de m 6 et il peut
shooter sur n'importe qui
il aura un rôle il aura un rôle et il
faudra peut-être déjà être un petit peu
créatif pour le développer un petit peu
plus notamment dans son rôle défensif ce
qu avec hugues on n'est pas d'accord là
dessus
et paulo est ce qu'il est plus ou moins
risqué pour toi hughie paulo il a plus
de potentiel mais il est plus risqué que
les deux autres dans le temps de temps
le fit
potentiel
pour les kings donc bah ouais parce que
ben ali qui en fait si tu di paolo parce
que petit magie n'est besoin de jouer 5
en gros oui
c'est ça
en tout cas déjà bah oui même si je
jouais avec sabonis qui défendent les
quatre ans dans un premier temps où les
cinq hommes sont corrélés pas encore
totalement formés ça me va paolo sabonis
t'as pas le choix ça vous dit défendre
les cinq du coût et il défend pas bien
les cinq sabonis et le lac ce pick and
roll fox est attaqué tu sais pour tout
faire tous les jours et ça va être 17
cibles et lounge à paris semi site offre
une piétonne gagnent encore plus
d'offres le luxe de choisir qui tu vas
faire défendre sur le live le pick and
roll est ce que tu vas mettre du coudiat
bah oui ou chet sur le 5 et du cou
sabonis à côté sur le moins bon landreau
ailiers adverses ou contraire et ça pour
moi cette offre plus de diversité et
pour le défendra pas les 5 paulo par
rapport à chatter jabbari smith il a
plus besoin du ballon en main même si
peut très bien je semble plus avoir
besoin du ballon en main et un tel cas
où qui dès le départ pro des ballons à
la paire fawkes sabonis orthez l'église
tu veux être compétitif aussi donc la
fois intégrer derrière et par le bunker
au jour les trois joueurs c'est
peut-être celui qu'a le tir extérieur
pour l'instant le moins abouti même si
moi je crois fortement sentir installé
notamment sentiront poulpe mais là le
tir extérieur le moins abouti était une
équipe avec sabonis cap un tir extérieur
abu sitta fox la partie extérieure
abouti et john mitchell moi je crois
dans le tireur mais a pas montré
forcément tout de suite harrison barnes
wittel bonne garantie donc comment
est-ce que tu organises ton sac majeur à
ce moment là pour jouer en nba parce
qu'on est plus rien signé et donc ça
fait beaucoup beaucoup de questions et
si je crois en paulo comme le meilleur
jour de la cuvée dans une franchise de
merde moi c'est mon un grand si je fais
une bord un board avec toutes les
équipes confondues peu importe le nom de
l'équipe et plans projetés lors de dents
aux kings il faut vraiment réfléchir
fortement et qui ne se réfléchir dès
fois malheureusement ça fait un peu peur
alors que je souhaite que le mail y aura
cette équipe
simon toi tu entends tu le prends le
celui des trois qui descendent même si
c'est risqué parce que tu te dis tu te
fais le même raisonnement qui avec ivy
du diois là où qu'avec charte qu'il y
ait trop de talent pour laisser passer
ouais clairement après en fonction de
qui tombe déjà filmés en gros pour moi
le gros lot c'est déjà barré si je pense
vraiment pour les fixes si on parle de
tours et unifier tout parce que je pense
qu'il médiatement
il appartement en défense comme graines
on met tout de suite en attaque c'est
incroyable de racheter sur l'aja barry
smith quoi on parlait du duo fox à boni
c'est tout je pense ça marche très vite
et d'ailleurs c'est la petite nuance je
suis d'accord quand tu te dis que tu
m'as vu ticket un tout petit but comme
graines toi tu le prends un a priori
pour le truc défensif moi j'arrive
presque tendance à à dire que le ski et
déjà déjà barry smith en attaque me fait
dire que si il progresse ne serait-ce
que un peu en défense mais ça joue
s'intituler allenby et dans n'importe
quelle équipe tous les jours en fait
parce que son shoot pour cette taille
fait que si en défense ils paris peut
juste être sur le terrain je te dis pas
dit mais qu'en fait il est assez bon
défensivement pour placer sur le terrain
parce qu'il veut pas être ciblés comme
défenseur d'un pick and roll parce que
voilà voilà pays peut être sur terre
sont moi je trouve que dans ce convoi de
son sont la fiabilité que dégage son
shoot me fait quand même assez
hallucinant voilà donc j'hésiterais
fortement tu vas être j'arrive pas les
départs et j'ai du mal parce que c'est
vrai que l'autre côté un grain en
défense c'est incroyable tout est un
délire à l'interné ce truc entre
kirienko et janis presque si tu imagines
s'il prend du poids tout potentiellement
qui fait que ça a pu être un candidat au
titre de défenseur de l'année sur une
décennie peut-être donc c'est un joueur
aussi très différent pierrot pour
synthétiser et beaucoup plus un joueur
presque un ancien un espèce de catala de
ce qu'on voit un bébé avec les griffin
des vagues comme ça et tout mais par
contre ce mec là effectivement dans les
années 90 2000 jusque il ya même générer
moins de 10 ans il est pris numéro un
tous les jours parce que l'on nba c'est
un espèce de mecque normalement
potentiellement il fait ses stats quel
que soit le schéma de jeu il fait vingt
dix tout ça et tout est effectivement
comble de l'ironie si c'est lui qui
glisse pour les kings c'est hyper chiant
parce qu'
il serait quasi n'est pas incompatible
non plus de mot est fort mais très très
très difficile à utiliser en même temps
que sabonis
que ce soit en attaque ou en défense
leur ceinture jeunes rageux draft quand
même et je fais un échange et montrent
un échange mais immédiatement madiot
téléphone et je dis voilà j'ai banque
héros il vous colle harrison parts dans
les pattes et c'est parti qui on veut
quoi et je sais que j'ai un joueur je
sens
oui
sur juste sur un grain n'a pas peut-être
que ça n'arrivera pas de toute façon
qu'on a failli passer non plus trop trop
longtemps mais moi je pense qu'il a plus
en magasin puisqu'il a montré
cette année en asie de l'est je suis
persuadé que sur sur sur des actions
d'ailleurs il le fait où il a un petit
peu obligé cette fin de possession elle
est un petit peu obligé contrairement au
jeu que développe gonzaga d'habitude de
créer un peu tout seul il va poser un
dribble il va faire un petit fail away
il sait faire quoi c'est pas c'est pas
la fluidité et la facilité des gages à
bari smic mais c'est mais c'est quelque
chose qui peut ressembler à
[Musique]
l'efficacité sur certaines phases en
neuvième
olive est ce que tu as une autre chose à
nous dire sur voilà est-ce qu'il ya un
des trois qui te fait saliver ce qu'il
ya un des trois montées sur kiel qu'il
irait très bien sur le parquet des kings
avec un maillot blanc et violet
alors moi du coup et j'ai une vision un
petit peu un petit peu pessimiste de la
chose vite les choses que j'ai dites là
c'est que pour moi s'il ya un mec qui
dit 104 je pense que ces banques héros
je pense pas que des toiles thunder the
magic qui laisse passer enfin je pense
pas que tu as une équipe du top 3 qui
laisse passer swatch est votre gabarit
pour moi il ya quelqu'un qui peut
craquer sur heidi may a personne qui va
dire réside chez tourisme mise puisque
maman c c'est vraiment l'air vraiment
d'être les deux toques talent 2 de la
draft donc on peut potentiellement se
retrouver avec l'opportunité voilà de
draft et drafté banque héros qui sur le
papier quand même il propose un renfort
à l'air allèles qui est non négligeable
qui nous voilà qu'il tombe quand même un
vrai pause 3 4 qui comble un manque
derrière potentiellement à côté ou
derrière harrison barnes 4 plutôt merci
et donc voilà qui sur le post il ya rien
à dire après voilà dans les qualités de
jeu que vous le décrivez c'est pas
forcément le
lepic idéale d'autant qu'il faudrait
qu'il développe vraiment son shoot qui
deviennent un vrai shooteur pour
compenser les points qui nous ferait
perdre en défense ils pourraient être
complémentaires en six axes
sabonis quoi
alors après je cite souvent gregg
popovich qui dit que deux jeux deux
intérieurs qui savent passer peuvent
jouer ensemble en quand paul aubin
gayraud et demanda sabonis sont tous les
deux très bon passeur c'est sans doute
possible mais là par contre c'est pour
ça qu'avec n'aura pas tant pardon un
genre prend la parole je pense que tu
draft banque héros tout de suite en 4
parce que tu as eu de la chance est
vraiment vite quand je dis vite c'est à
pelleter 3 vous le voulez en fait nous
on prend votre pique là tout de suite
maintenant par contre c'est déjà ravi
vente ces machins et vous prenez des
merdes a noué temps de l'urgence je
pense que si c'est pas eu tu continues
avec portland tu continues tu india la
fin j'ai pas d'ordre par dont celle
inverse mais tu continues tu connais et
tu es tant que t'as pas quelqu'un qui
prend environ tu vois je suis très tu te
pose même pas la question de la
comptabilité au compatibilité tout le
temps pis mais par contre tu vas
chercher un mec de 25 ans allèles
situent les raids billets garantis et où
es-tu tejari saint barth c'était je
crois
je pense ça m'embête de la part d'un
maire de salies met d'accord avec toi il
dit
il faut récupérer jeramy grande dans le
bazar alors est ce que le désigne
sacramento dans le bazar ça comme bazar
bon bah moi je vois plus dans le trait
il ne comprend pas le 4 mai oui oui tu
sais où tu racontes c'est devenu urgent
d'installer un truc de ouf les gens mais
j'en vois l'homme élu thuram iguerande
c'est à dire la tristesse du marché
woippy mais ces bons à moyen terme vas-y
où les
parents résident c'était juste pour
rebondir sur des rames et grandes qui
est apparemment qui au sein de l'as fan
des kings en tout cas us la fanbase des
crises qui est vraiment l'homme
providentiel tu le vends à peu près 90%
de démocrates qui sont faits l'a
peut-être pas tout le temps dira
migrantes dans l'eau donc
fait si c'est un fantasme c'est un
fantasme collectif après est ce que je
me dis simon tu arrives à des tarifs à
detroit avec bang héros et et de 3 à 7
sont plus est ce que tu peux monter un
trade ouais c'est pas c'est pas
impossible pour le coup ce serait sera
pas déconner
on va je pense que ces trois banques et
rodgers 6 6/10 qu'est ce que tu veux en
plus que les 10
attendu les vraiment très bien non mais
dans leurs projets et où je pense que tu
d'aimer vraiment très bien et tout de
suite avoir connu une gamme bang héros
je pense de ram une grande ses valises
il a ils l'emmènent honnêtement il
laisse pas passer un truc pareil fin
peut-être que je suis resté muet et
c'est là où ta chance de piquer en 4
avec un mec comme ça qu'ils glissent
serait un jackpot fausse eu par contre
faut pas faire la connerie fin pour moi
de commencer à aston pour gregg popovich
parce qu'on n'est pas grave au plus vite
malheureusement et à se dire moi je les
fais jouer ensemble machin et ou quoi
c'est parce qu'en fait tu ris d'un quart
des banques et on est de faire baisser
sa valeur par rapport au soir vannes où
il est drafté où c'est la panique c'est
ce qu'on disait qui est très exigeant
what the fuck jerada déjà des vies par
an 2 qu'est ce qui se passe qu'on est
tous les modes tout tout tout dégage ça
c'est même un scénar moi je sais bien
qu'on en parle franchement parce que il
revient vous déçu de voir aussi revient
quand même temps il ya quand même un peu
et puis ils font que l'attention ivy qui
pourrait être le joueur apparemment ce
serait lui si un mec montrent des photos
bordel vient des quilles et le podium on
est d'accord c'est ça j'ai l'impression
qui ressort si un mec ouais
il à main ou dennis b lettre
tous
ouais on a personal top3 jabbari smith
le soir de la draft par le funky route
c'est tellement une fois qu'on a tous un
jour soit ça soit heidi tueur dans le
top 3
c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer on sait pas forcément de no
border on pense tous y en a un qui va
glisser parce que voilà encore
des morts et fait deux morts
deux des big board
mais le le fit des halles au prince est
pas par hasard oui c'est ce que disait
hugo début pour moi c'est un très un
trade d'inde et tu vas chercher un gars
un peu plus sur quoi on peut plus sur
bâti sur de larges pages de new delhi le
tu penses aux
c'est bien johnny davis pour moi c'est
un morcellement jalbert
mathurin il se la raconte un peu donc
donc je ne sais pas à quelle fin
j'arrive à faire
pour moi mon scénario idéal là dedans ce
serait peut-être portland on va dire
partez jo charte est drafté griffin
hockey et olive qu'un scénario idéal on
est un homme proche de la santé
moi je
j'aime beaucoup le trade de travail de
simon dans le sens où tu récupères quand
même de vrais joueurs capables
d'apporter immédiatement et sur les
ailes mais je me dis que [ __ ] quand
même un pic 4 on n'a pas tous les jours
que là ça fait tellement d'années qu'on
note que fait tellement d'années qu'on
galère qu'on est con et à la draft où
les vents et on en a eu un seul pic dans
notre histoire c'était bien vu que
c'était permis celi seule fois ci pas de
bêtises simon battu corrigera me contre
1 à 9 soit là et voilà c'est ça 89 c'est
ça voilà du coup on a un âge elle
enseignait retrouve avec un pic avec un
pic sociaux c'est vraiment une des rares
fois aussi où on monte la draft et moi
je trouve ça dommage de dalles et reidar
nous d'aller chercher un joueur nba
ready un truc comme ça avec ce pic 4 moi
j'aime bien l'idée de de prendre un
risque de drafter ou potentiels et des
hôpitaux et vivre avec vivre avec ont
suivi ils ont que c'est les aléas d'un
pic à 3,6 tu sélectionnes un mec qui
vaut un pic 4 et puis après si ça se
passe bien ça se passe mal battu
l'assument derrière quoi mais mais ça se
comprendra peut-être mais voilà moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien les scénarios on
va chercher du était greffier le truc
comme ça un peu plus bas mais je me dis
que quand même merde psy4 c'est quand
même dommage
vu que c'est quoi ton meilleur scénario
chez moi si je fais une moc là comme ça
vite fait je t'avais dit que je faisais
le trail le truc je crois que c'était
les roquettes ce que sharp par tobrouk
est et que moi du coup j'avais déjà
barry smith qui tombait et ça c'est le
truc de ouf pour moi om moi j'aime chez
moi j'avais déjà barry smith qui tombait
mais parce que chez moi il ta tête et
paulo qui sont devant et j'ai pu que les
ricains ont actuellement de jabba will
smith est un an et voilà je lis un peu
je t'aime juste
pour tana
mouammar et fils de barry smith optics
ce serait incroyable moi je préférais
sinon pape a donné trois leur parle de
sacramento mais non mais smith le aux
kings
et je pense pas que ce soit si déconnant
que sa fin si improbable que ça et sinon
et jerry finn peut-être donné jerry finn
j'aime beaucoup parce que je pense qu'on
on crache un peu trop chaud et jerry
finn dans la save à l'heure actuelle
parce qu'ils sont dans les moquées et
que c'est ce qu'ils les grawls
voilà il sera aux platines au sénégal
c'est ça et qu'un antécédent médical tu
vois mais sur le joueur mais dont le
potentiel dans la mentalité dans le dans
la potentialité et ses dauphines peut
être un excellent joueur et ça peut être
très compatible avec le jim donc cm2
sinon de 14,7 sûr de bien comprendre toi
tu traites dorn ou en groupe dont le
règne de six à neuf pour gratter un
vétéran graff téléfilm contre plus de
400 rennes c'était ça
ok moi je pense que j'ai très bien
frappé je préfère gratter johnny davis à
edge griffin puisque
à une idée vis tu vraiment succion
[Musique]
quasiment
on entendait encore ouais c'est
jeune c'est qu'il est sait pas quand
même c'est moi où il est il a un peu
petit pour être trois quand même non ça
va j'ai plus ou moins 6
7 6 5 6
dans la dans la nba maintenant avec
beaucoup de line rider hasard
mais comme ivy d'ailleurs à lui même ce
qu'il est petit il était il a tellement
des épaules et tous les je pense qu'ils
peuvent passer des séquences sur des
trois adversaires tant que c'est pas des
trois pour re cité pour la dixième fois
paul george
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on
conclut qu'on a conclu le premier tour
parce que de toute façon on va pas
vraiment concluants mais notre scénario
idéal chacun donc simon
soit il ya un jabbari smith qui descend
simon et udaf d'ailleurs sur un même
longueur d'onde
ce soir rêve soit on traite d'une
piscine
moi je trade bank pourra pour aller
chercher peut-être un johnny davis même
si j'ai beaucoup et jean guy finn qui va
t'apporter du suspect singh dans un
premier temps un premier peut-être plus
après et les olives qui nous avait dit
qu'est ce que tu
vois je le vois drafté si j'avais pas
clairement donné un choix de hausse mais
je nous vois bien je vois sélectionné
avec les pics 4 en fait quel que soit le
plus gros potentiel disponible au piquet
ok pour oui parce que je vais arrêter ce
compte que son qu'est-ce qu'on veut qu
est ce qui va se passer tu vois
moi je pense comme toi 3 va pas bouger
et combattre
si je reste sur ce qui va se passer de
plus probable je pense qu'en france
paraît le plus probable par contre je
pense que les gars vous rêvez de
personnes
c'est plus probable on a tous d'accord
chez les peaches siad doualeh c'est
effectivement là là là là plus la cote
la plus faible second tour j'ai mille
bande au second tour quelques fils vous
voulez est ce que vous voulez draft est
ce que vous voulez olive est-ce que de
draft et et deux pick une 37 39 47 sa
39 que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est la 49 g + horaires des deux cinq
et cinquante les d'euros
mais évidemment une fois mais que la
plus importe l'âge ou quoi que ce soit
il faut un maquis qui s'échouent t il
faut absolument d absolument des
shooteurs parce que là je sais pas qui
on va drafté avec les flics cave mais
voilà il faut il te faut un mec capable
d'allumer de manière constante derrière
l'arc voilà pour représenter le menace
extérieure pour laisser de la place à
sotchi sabonis dessous il est maladroit
justin holiday puisque je vois qu'il est
dans votre effectif je sais pas si
j'estime que les dés cilicie rentrer 1,1
tirons des contents c'est à dire que
vraiment ça a été plutôt 10 km route il
ne parle pas du même au leader mais jack
sock x était plutôt catastrophique
mais voilà dix vincenzo c'était un petit
peu irrégulier il est meilleur sur le
sur des situations de catch and shoot
des villes mais chez le simple pareil un
peu irrégulier voilà il ya des shooteurs
descend à 3 points mais t'as pas le mec
tu dis je vais lui donner la balle et
c'est lui qui va me mettre mon tir à
trois points c'est un peu un peu ce
genre de profil dont on aurait besoin
d'un gars capable d'étirer le jeu et de
claquer de manière constante alors déjà
sur ce profil peut-être que six mois
notre profil en tête mais déjà sur ce
profil hugues est ce que tu as des
choses à vendre
bah oui
c'est de la valeur marchande un tel qu
il a été changé pour une photocopieuse
tu vois donc on peut pas on peut dire
des choses
sur le navigateur monaco motards qui dit
j'ai parlé coréenne
yu zhang li le shooteur de davidson qui
tirent très très bien pour le coup mais
qui pour moi serait pas un assez bon
défenseur j'aimerais beaucoup christiane
braux du côté de sacramento le jour de
kansas le très athlétique vrai vrai
tireur grosse mentalité etc qui pourrait
réussir l'épreuve 3,4 et que manu par
neo mais tous synchro et eddy le
shooteur de kentucky qui est un gros
saut spécial un gros spécialistes qui
peut aussi défendre sur les postes 2 3
assez athlétique qu'il bouge très très
bien on va supprimer mais non et en
priorité j'aurais christiane gross il
encore disponibles je gérais source
m'éclate très rapidement et c'est nous
les johnnies
abassi mais jeudi 12 1 que à sacramento
c'est la théorie de l'échec pas de fin
serra simple moi j'aimerais un mec un
peu avec bonne mentalité stable fiable
est juste un pion romane quoi je veux un
gabon où je sais que dans la deûle et
défensivement servir aussi de 12,1 en c1
il faut qu'ils aillent aux lakers
cela doit être costaud mentalement
christiane round qui a qui n'a pas la
souplesse du jeu puisque notre notre
administrateur du site de antoine
bérenger avait avait coutume de dire
s'il enlève le ballet qu'il a quelque
part il pourrait être un bon joueur et
effectivement c'est un bon joueur c'est
un bon shooteur cette année 38 %
38,6 pour cent à trois points sur trois
tentatives
jamais non plus énormément brillé aux
lancers mais c'est un joueur athlétique
est effectivement qui surtout était le
deuxième meilleur défenseur peut-être
kansas donc quand je vois assez
polyvalent pour christiane grande
j'ai également
en magasin
normalement un autre prend aux specs que
tu as cité u des quais language
qui lui vieux
mais dont on est peut-être encore plus
sûr du tir
puisque à regarder un sur six tentatives
en moyenne à 3 mois et presque à 38%
carrière donc c'est à dire que le gars
est un shooter à peu près certain
qu'elle and ready qui a fini sa carrière
alors une très longue carrière nba
puisque maintenant pour ceux qui se
posent la question lui c'est toujours
quatre ans mais il ya une année
supplémentaire
commentaires que vides et et tutti
quanti et plus des années red shirt
éventuelle fin bref il ya des types mais
à 30 ans mais 126 donc and ready va
avoir 25 ans cette année donc c'est vrai
que c'est un peu
mais bon sur un contrat de deuxième tour
ça dure deux ans donc au pire c'est
peut-être c'est pas un gros gros risques
sinon est ce que tu es d'accord sur le
fruit nba ce que tu vois d'autres
d'autres profils enfin surtout les
fruits et le dit on verra oui moi sur le
deuxième tour de façon les gars je vais
pas vous mentir je suis forcément on est
avec vous parce qu'il le soit toi ô une
balançoire et des noms de marques de nfl
que je ferais huawei
distinguer de maintenant mais justement
non mais moi c'est de moi je te pose la
question du profil genre est-ce que tu
target du ring runner du backup meneur
du du spécialiste défense c'est pas bon
a priori du shoot et éventuellement en
tout cas des profils que t'as pas
forcément donc peut-être si afrique
athlétique au poste de pivot à long
terme pourquoi pas tu vois qui est
disponible s'il a juste pas de petits
bonheurs de poche peut-être déjà pas de
meneurs qui pas grand à deux mètres et
badelj et qui sait pas shooter qui va ça
rien
death ou joe jackson on n'en veut pas
voilà un pour aller vite ou des huit
disciplines sauf un des sous c'est sous
l'éclat des mecs très synthétique hyper
forissier mais qui en fait n'ont pas de
eelv on va commencer par les développer
on sait pas s'en servir après mois pour
être honnête sur les deuxièmes tours
j'ai toujours un peu la méthode jeu en
général j'essaie de je me focalise sur
les joueurs de loterie ça tombait à
prendre et xange rien du tout parce que
j'ai pas autant de temps et j'avais pas
après je me vais m'intéresser à partir
de là la femme premier tour un peu tout
le monde je sais pas mais moi je suis
j'ai ce problème de fonctionner
vachement o'keefe sur les noms c'est
d'évidence que je alors
le deuxième tome facile je fais toujours
un tour en une semaine deux semaines
avant pour regarder les blast des types
et là tu as toujours un gars tu peux
être sûr qu'à toujours un mec on dirait
c'est un tarantino ça sort d'un fil du
temps sinon à chaque année tamar jeunes
bonchamp mais non des noms des blazes
incroyable que cela puisse faire est
forcément moi je suis pour lui et je
veux que les kicks draft le mec je vous
dis que precious a chihuahua tombe au
king's par exemple oui voilà
sept ans la jeune je roule évidemment
des hornets
malgré
ce serait étonnant qu'ils glissent ils
appellent un peu de code surtout qu'il a
fait la g-league light night
mais après il peut être peut glisser
jusqu'en fin de trentaine mais
effectivement nous on n'est pas hyper
fan enfin si une toi tu la plus haute
marge mais moi je suis moi je considère
qu'il veut pas trop tirer
je suis pas je suis pas fan moi j'adore
jake la radio ona plein plein de
alors jake larabia 7 7 7 fait sonner
l'oreille simon pas tu me dis je dois en
donner un max de soprano ouais enfin
c'est un vrai joueur c'est que la belle
assure le voir sur le match je me base
sur celle de kevin o'connor
et on a 40 sérieux que là j'ai su qu'ils
allaient lice
chez vous
''j'ai clara via ça s est très variable
mais moi par exemple dans mon board il
est 27e
dans le port de consensus il est plus
bas donc il est bas mais ouais t'as
raison botchan pour l'as 35 68
oui
voilà on en a christiane brown 42 comme
disait hugues jake larabia 48 yu zhang
li donc le coréen 40
et après il ya des jeunes et de jouer
johnny zhujiang c'est un bon nom quand
même moi j'aime bien
johnny toulousaine
reste du monde mais c'est quasiment pour
d'autres et autres mais moi je rêve que
j'ai ce matin kamagaté sera fait par les
kiwis est ce que parce que tu le suis tu
l'a suivi ouais ouais cette année n'ont
pu même en plus en terme de profil et ou
franchement ce serait pas mal de travail
et un pivot défensif et puis voilà donc
[Musique]
où même sans l'avoir si tu vas mais ça
pour le kiff qu'hugo besson sawgrass
optique bah pourquoi pas tu vois ce
serait cool ça fait longtemps puisqu'il
ya pas eu ça fait plusieurs mois que
c'est le français sait quand même que
celle de loire ouais c'est ça pour moi
je vois ça fait quand même et sa
dernière
25 ans qu'un français a pas porté le
maillot des kings un truc comme ça parce
qu'un de loi ses traits d auneau gets
l'agent reason gaming
au deuxième tour c'est c'est possible il
ya pas mal de français qui sont là les
kamagaté les makoun ou et
gober son
audience sera sans doute déjà partis
mais partie mais ya pas mal pas mal
effectivement deux candidats la draft
second tour un mot de conclusion olive
sur la draft des kings est ce que tu as
plus peur ou confiance toit par exemple
j'ai peur parce que quand on associe
drafté kinks dans une seule phrase
forcément ça fait toujours peur
j'ai confiance dans le sens où on a
quand même monté ma mère aux banettes et
voilà on a il a quand même trouvé qu'il
savait de quoi il parlait et qui sait
quand même des bons move
voilà qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure suite
sabonis on peut dire ce qu'on veut il ya
quand même y'a quand même un fond ne
font penser quelque chose voilà il a
tenté un truc qui s'est dit aujourd'hui
je peux avoir le star je me fais là il a
draftés il a bien drafté les deux choix
qu'il a fait voilà je pense moi j'ai
confiance j'ai confiance en ce joueur
donc j'arrive à la draft serein je me
dis le mec va faire peut-être que ça va
être un pic décevant genre qui gagnerait
un truc comme ça peut tourner au en tout
cas mais voilà je sais je sais que le
mec qui va qui va arriver cette draft ça
va être un gars qui va apporter ça va
être un gars qui va être utile aux kings
moi je
c'est intime sentiment que voilà un
thème avec mary c'est ce qui fait est
que je peux le jeu peut lui faire
confiance aujourd'hui donc le sort de la
drogue est évidemment stressé comme pas
possible même trois jours un grand coup
voilà je vais transpirer à grosses
gouttes parce que on peut toujours
sortir une dinguerie mais voilà je reste
confiant parce que voilà c'est pas lisse
et plus vous la dédie belge qui peut
sortir une énorme dinguerie
le soir de la draft est quand même cgm
qui avait calé pieds sur terre qui a un
semblant projet qui peut faire quelque
chose de sympa
sinon même question
pardon je n'ai de réponse est au moment
où s'ébat que l'équipe ripa dont sytchev
sans
jamais y penser mais oui mais c'était
pas au moment où je n'étais pas c'était
pas mal mais on ne peut pas monter non
non non je l'aimais bien je l'aimé bien
moi au départ vous allez en plus sur
écoute moi même question réponse je suis
refait depuis que je sais que dans le
board d'hugo fin dans la possible mort
afd hugo djabaret smith est pas
peu tombée aux kings donc moi je suis
pas venu pour rien je suis content
l'attendaient à bari maintenant est ce
que tu vois je vais le foot dans touquet
aux kings et tous non plus sérieusement
mais ça reflète mon état d'esprit ceci
je suis content parce que je pense quand
même que avec un jam correct mackler
avec
là
il ya quand même quelque chose faut que
sabonis pour revenir à ça il ya une
espèce de base de jeu qui est quand même
assez sympa etc et voilà deux joueurs
quand même de calibre reconnu et où il
ya la possibilité de faire parce qu'on a
vu on a été en fait sur tous les
scénarios le plafond de même en faisant
une connerie les kings devrait pas trop
mal s'en sortir ces salles d'examen
rapide 4 aussi on l'a pas dit mais c'est
une évidence quand on fait les cons avec
un pic tagliani bertone s'est on a on a
une espèce de coup de génie avec un pie
xii et beaucoup de chance à tous mais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait les cons avec des
pics 7-8-9 la lèche tosca ce thomas
froome initiales maq les mots mal
clément jamais aussi c'est plutôt baba
janice être mais dans l'ensemble le jeu
mac lémance je montre c'est même pas 5
tu vois moi que les morges doute c'est
thomas sorensen peut-être 5g plus je lui
ai aussi dit d'ailleurs été annoncé
l'elysée mais clémence 6ème mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire là on a quatre
et en fait 4 c'est cool parce que ça
veut dire que même en faisant un peu de
gris ou quels que soient les scénarios
tous tes assez safe parce que tu piques
quand même dans les bas 4e quoi et que
on va faire quoi en faire une connerie
reprendre lui donne sharp ou bon et puis
en tête en tête mais ça va tu vois c'est
moi c'est moi qu'il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas un délire âge tosca sous nous avons
des lacs est fort nous normalement il ya
quand même un pin 4 pardon pour les abus
vois ce que je veux dire mon état
d'esprit plus nombreux
[Musique]
il ya un tel calcul d'intérêt l'air
hagard sur twitch tout seul diani
mulhouse est
depuis trois quatre ans j'ai quand même
le temps un peu long mais non mais un
pic un pic 4 tu vois tu garantie quand
même deux on va finir avec déjà deux
d'avis et bon peut-être qu'ils gagnent
murray qui seraient entre guillemets
d'accueil riba qui ont fait la fine
bouche parce que en fait si on était
resté 7,8 à la loterie on aurait été
content d'avoir qui calmerait vrai ce
que je veux dire le fit y colle le mec
il est pas fou il sait jouer au basket
ça va dans toi hugo wybo griffin par
exemple ans à tous vite tu vois et au
pire
on aura griffith parce qu'on va très
tendance hills avec chaque âge a donc je
suis assez serein quand même par contre
pour finir si l'équipe se trouve le
moyen de faire encore un truc équivalent
à bac des dons seach là
je sais pas moi je rejoins les mecs sur
la suisse
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît
donc simon je te présente hughes qui
crie qui n'est pas oui ghosn
estime qu à mes choix du dollar baptisée
hugo mais je trouve ça lui va bien pas
grave si je suis même soigner son
ego peut passer pour
une des conquêtes
oui moi je pense que ça va bien se
passer les gars ça va ça va aller le
plein de bons joueurs il ya deux plans
scénario plein de les pousser plein de
trucs donc ça va aller j'aime beaucoup
votre james je crois donc allez savoir
ce qui se passe
huguet on il nous reste un épisode à
faire c'est un il me semble pour ces
prêts doivent talk est ce que tu peux
annoncer quand c'est à ceux qui sont
encore là nous allons garder et ce sera
sur twitch ouais alors même deux
normalement même deux jeux et vendredi
la note vendredi 10 22 heures 23 heures
et ça devrait être avec les pélicans on
va parler de la draft des pélicans qui
ont le pic 8 et g la semaine prochaine
le 17 et on va recevoir les hornets et
on va recevoir aussi les si je te dis
pas de conneries
les hornets et l'espérance donc voilà
c'est démographe franche histoire
maintenant la loterie tranquillement et
elle a raté toute la loterie en fait
toute la loterie ou ton presque
internet 51 13 15 qui salue bien
normalement s'en tienne c'est une vraie
target pour trait de bach aussi un
hornet si tu veux vraiment redback loin
c'est un veau bien de coordonnées ward
et il est pas si simple
non mais c'est un peu cher mais
oh [ __ ] on va pas faire ça olivier
olive on va pas faire ça
vous venez vendredi 10 sept vous venez
le 17 et par l'ensemble avec les fans de
renaître
il remercie soupçons d'accord mais
[Rires]
on est sûr d'une chose c'est qu'on va
rigoler
parce que soit vous allez avoir peur et
sa famille ce qui se passait mais on
aurait quand même bien rigolé soit vous
allez faire une grosse connerie on
pourra rigolé après tu sais quand
aux livres merci beaucoup de ton temps
pour edouard ce jour-là invitation
spéciale king c'est ce qui se passe des
choses sur king france d'ici là d'un
bon espace des choses tranquillement là
on est en train de sortir des petits
articles de profils de draft un peu sur
les sur des cibles notamment pie iv ou
en cas de trafic d'armes donc on est en
train de faire sortir vite le children
au fur et à mesure on en profite pour
saluer les petits rédacteurs théo thomas
nico notamment qui écrivent des modes
excellent papier sur la n6 et parce
qu'ils suivent ça toute l'année donc un
big up a eux et puis évidemment comme
tous les ans maintenant c'est devenu une
tradition depuis la dinguerie
2018 on va faire un petit live
évidemment pour sup la draft en direct
de rejoindre nos petites têtes pour nos
petites têtes en direct sur un an selon
ce qui se passe donc voilà créé à
l'actualité des prochains jours pour
créer des mêmes ça évidemment exactement
et sinon ça fait très plaisir de
participer à votre émission
non mais leur plein d'infos que j'avais
pas j'ai appris plein de trucs là on en
en discutant avec vous en échangeant
siècle
lexie mon depuis voit donc c'était très
sympa merci à vous c'est normal vous
êtes des bons clients est toujours sympa
en vrai gentil non mais c'est super
c'est super cool merci merci les jours
dans le chat aussi
j'aimerais merci pour tout coulon
participation ça s'est très bien passé
encore une fois dans le tchat
beaucoup de bienveillance malgré des
avis divergents carrément
non s'ils montent à un prix cassé toi
ah
je sais pas trop si j'ai le droit en
fait mais je pense
pas ce commandant mais c'est ici que je
veux faire de manière intelligente il ya
certains ont peut-être déjà vu donc
attend depuis
le début de l'année je crois sur bin
sport sont diffusés des matchs de
betclic et dites donc de première
division de basket français et
en parallèle à sa depuis maintenant
depuis je crois qu'il ya des missions
sur les trophées ça fait deux semaines
je pense qu'il ya un teaser qui passe un
peu comme ça sur un document où on voit
des joueurs je pas si vous l'avez vu ce
qui passe sans que soutiennent les
jeunes français quoi voilà tout est dit
et il se trouve que j'ai eu la chance de
faire partie du projet depuis le début
de ce projet quoi donc sa conception et
ses atouts en tant que
voilà deux procès deux succès ses
joueurs dont qui sont cinq pensionnaires
c'est bien ce mot là mais et des donc on
a évolué de quelqu'un m'a gâté ismaël
johan backlund ou match oppose à matthew
strazeele
je veux des gars 1 est aussi un rôle un
peu intermédiaire puisque lui et déjà
l'an dernier
et j'aime bien et mylène bar beach
évidemment
et c'est diffusé à partir du 15 juin si
je dis pas de bêtises en sous forme
d'épisodes donc là il y aura quatre
épisodes qui vont être diffusés quatre
épisodes un quart d'heure globalement
qui vont être diffusés je ne sais pas à
quelle fréquence encore retourner sur
bin sport là à partir du 15 au tour de
la draft etc voilà merci d'avoir fait
penser en peluche mba non mais si on
veut en savoir plus sur les nouvelles
pépites du basket français et avoir un
bassin vrai regard
voilà proche proche de avec des
interviews fait cela c'est que ces
terrasses et c'est un peu en mode
coulisses passé
c'est ça on a bon dans le jargon moi
j'aime pas forcément ça mais c'est vrai
que le mot anglais a pas d'équipé en
france en la personne insight parce
qu'en fait c'est l'été comme le font
certains clubs qu'on les a accompagnés
dont convenait à des matches même si
elle est en travers plusieurs fois pour
avoir comme ça une évolution en faveur
de la saison manquée entre le raid au
plus sportif tu aurais pu être sur un
des joueurs mais nous ce qu'on a voulu
faire et qui est un peu court pour la
peine de paris première mais qui est
assez rare dans les formats classiques
de ce qu'on a vécu de voir en france en
tout cas produire en france on les à
entremêler donc on a choisi d'en suivre
plusieurs aides entre mais des comme ça
alors pas forcément à chaque fois on n'a
pas des cinq dans chaque épisode c'est
vraiment entre m'aider et ça c'était
code qu'on a pu le voir dans la
narration de série quoi par exemple où
tu où les personnages vont s'entremêler
c'est tout c'est un truc intermédiaires
et second inside parce qu'effectivement
on y voit aussi un endroit dans la vie
de tous les jours chez eux
[Musique]
voilà à découvrir sur turbine une
occasion de vous dire j'ai même pas si
je les ai déjà dit que nous nous
envergure seront présents
le soir de la draft turbine à puisqu'il
y aura romain leroy en plateau avec rémy
reverchon et je sais pas si c'est
habituel bob sudre qui fera il fera le
troisième compère
nous on sera évidemment chez la force
team avec avec thomas et erwan et puis
grave qu'elle ne peut être à suivre avec
king france également si vous êtes fan
des kings et que vous voulez avoir des
réactions extraordinaire aux moments
difficiles 4 donc donc voilà il ya plein
il y aura plein d'options est énorme
pour tous les goûts et d'ici là on a
encore des modes grâce des big board à
vous proposer abonnez vous à une chaîne
youtube et abonnez vous aussi au podcast
si vous voulez mener sur toutes les
plateformes d'écouté vous avez juste à
cliquer sur sur la cloche sur le coeur
ça dépend de la plateforme merci simon
merci olive merci hughes ont rendu
l'antenne de ceux qui drafté pré draft
aux sacramento kings on se retrouve très
bientôt ciao